i'll give you my duck supreme
that's my everybody's too high song
right when it's like oh no
this guy's [ __ ] high yeah hang on
and we're rolling what's up brother how
are you what's going on how are you
got you in here man finally i'm finally
here i'm happy to be light huh this is
your [ __ ]
yeah come on all right cheers sir why
not
pleasure also precursor i haven't slept
i know we haven't slept around mushrooms
and uh
let's roll yeah [ __ ] it we'll do it live
let's do it live [ __ ] it
why utah man why you live in utah what's
that about
i have no idea have you are you from
there no sir
i was born in syracuse new york yeah it
is it's absolutely exciting
i love it it's got a good vibe too
because
it's this it's almost like utah is a
secret because everybody's scared of the
mormons
so they don't go there right but then
you get there like jesus christ it's
beautiful and these mormons are so nice
everybody's so nice everybody's so nice
in utah and um
you know i did so i don't remember what
tour it was exactly but there were
supposed to be 5
000 people to show up and then we end up
getting to the show and there's 17
000 people so we had to move it outside
of the venue
right on the salt flats oh wow and i was
just like
if this isn't a sign from
god or the aliens you know the aliens
then i don't know what is so i looked at
houses on zillow and i found one and fix
it all up and
that's awesome now i've been there two
years just about
that's a good it's a good spot for a guy
like you too because it's chill
in comparison to the rest of your life
which is so crazy yeah well that's the
whole [ __ ] i couldn't do
la i couldn't do la like
i moved like i said from syracuse to
dallas
and then dallas to la when i was 18 and
i
it's it's a lot for me and i couldn't
focus
the way that i needed to right so on
your music
yeah and on every like there's always
you know before covid there's always
something
going on right like 24 7 like
it could be eight in the morning it
could be
what time is it right now two o'clock
something yeah
and then you gotta go do a podcast or
you gotta go to like a
a rooftop pool party or something
and you know being in utah it's so
[Music]
peaceful like you said and you get to
focus on the music and
wake up to the mountain yeah and the sun
sets at
10 p.m which is bizarre right around
this time
yeah it's just nuts you know it is it is
bizarre right
like now it's especially bizarre
utah's always got a weird vibe man like
zion national park you go out there to
the rocks and skinwalker ranch
i've been there have you yeah nothing
happened though we went there for a tv
show we're like come on aliens
where are you you [ __ ] they weren't
behind you you don't know tyler
tyler the alien oh no
yeah that's my dog you were telling me
yeah his best friend's name is ziggy did
they visit you in the middle of the
night
no they don't they just visit me during
the day we just play beer pong
damn if you do the right drugs you can
meet the aliens
we were talking about that in the green
room if you do the right amount of
mushrooms
in a tank getting a float tank you can
meet aliens
well that's whenever you're you're most
vulnerable like you said most vulnerable
most most susceptible to that's that's
why i like weed you know we were talking
about
weed makes you vulnerable and i think
for someone like me that's a good thing
to like think that way to think
sure think just just look at
all the vulnerabilities and just the
reality of life and the temporary nature
of it which
makes me more appreciative right like
the fear actually makes me more
appreciative
but mushrooms are a different animal man
they just bring you to this weird place
that's like right next door
you know it's like it's like a hall pass
to this other place
like you get like a vip bracelet you get
to go into another room that's right
there all the time
but you can't go in until you get that
bracelet
yeah and that's the whole thing like uh
i i've been doing these microdoses for a
while
and you don't really catch it until you
do like 10
like right off the rip but then i ate
these chocolates the other day
some shroomies chocolates and
me and my my producer lou we made a uh
a coachella set for about two hours wow
based off of the roblox do you know
roblox yes
i have girls young daughters so you know
when you're older
do you know do you know the death sound
of roblox no what's the sound
that's what happens when you die yeah
and then i sampled it and we made a
whole two-hour set off of the deal with
just a [ __ ] four to the floor kick
drum and it was the time of my life
wow and i felt like i got that vip
wristband and i was backstage at ziggy
and tyler's concert the aliens
do you feel like that sometimes when
ideas come to you when you're [ __ ] up
like it's almost like like it's a gift
from somewhere
i have no idea i think
all of my ideas are kind of like
mistakes
it's like because you never wake up and
say today i'm gonna write
the you know congratulations or any or
any song
and you kind of just it's it's all about
like
right moment right time yeah like i had
oh
i had like eight bud lights right
and then i took just a tiny bit of
shrooms and then here it's like
and then it just happens yeah there's
it's it's like
it is an accident it is just like
a spur of the moment type deal to where
you're like let me
sing this melody over this b
or let me make this be even and
it just kind of happens i don't know
well that's the flow state right when
you just you can get out of your own way
and you can let ideas come to you like i
was talking with this dude
his name is joe desenna he runs the
spartan race he's a really smart car
very interesting guy he does a lot of
stuff for kids he's got all these kid
programs these kids do
like difficult tasks and it like to do
it over a summer camp it gets them
better
but we were talking about it and we were
talking about being healthy and all the
benefits of being healthy sure
and i was like this there's a lot to
that but
there's also a lot to like the person
who binges and creates something
incredible like
we were talking about stephen king's
books like some of the ones he doesn't
even remember right are the best ones
because he was on coke and drinking
a [ __ ] case of bud like he just
blasted out of his head
chain smoking cigarettes and he doesn't
even remember writing i think it's cujo
he doesn't even remember writing it
like wrote carrie half blacked out you
read that book today man that is one of
the short
[ __ ] hearts my dad's the biggest
stephen king's fan
stephen king fan dude and then he's
amazing
but i i mean at the end of the day it's
like uh
to each his own you know what i mean i
mean whatever gets you through
through the night no some people can
definitely do it straight and and
you know i've definitely had ideas
without any influence of anything before
right but i feel like sometimes things
come to you when
when you're like a little high at least
right a little drunk and they're like i
don't know if i would have ever thought
about this
without the weed they just come out of
nowhere
that's what and that's and that's the
whole thing too like drinking rose or
drinking
you know bud light and then a little bit
of just the
something else yeah whether it be you
know smoking a little bit of a jake
cause i
i'm an anxious person you told me before
you're not an anxious person
but not really but i used to smoke a lot
but now not so much maybe i'll smoke
watch a funny movie
and then [ __ ] but it's it's
that stroke genius and you're like if i
was
nothing in my blood right now but just
blood
no booze no anything
would i have thought of that and that's
a that's the whole different deal
it's it's uh it's wild really i think
apart the way i think of wakeboarding
sure because uh when you're wakeboarding
and you're on that wave it look i don't
wakeboard but when i watch people do it
i don't wait for it either
it looks awesome right when they're on
that and they're catching those waves
but then when they wipe out man they go
down hard that's like wheat
so you're not gonna stay on that board
forever if you get really [ __ ] up
that board's going to flip over and
you're going to whenever you rip that
big ass
trick you do the behind the back double
spin
that's a stroke of genius and that's
that's what i think
that there's a certain magic that goes
into making
a record or you know if if you're a
painter a painting
or if you're a dancer a [ __ ] cool
dance move
i think they're all related in some way
yeah there's something there that yeah
that
just kicks off and you can't control it
and you can't
say when it's gonna happen but it just
happens whatever that is that that makes
humans so interested in creating things
that other people can enjoy
but that's that's what it is it's like
there's a weird frequency
humans creating things that they know
other people are going to enjoy and if
you can just get lost in the beauty of
just
creating the thing and get out of your
own way then these
ideas will come to you but if you get in
your own way you have less bandwidth for
the ideas
and when they come to you they've it
feels like this isn't
they're even yours like it's like you're
interacting with something
like these ideas just like if you have
an idea for like a
if i have an idea for a new bid or
something like that sometimes they just
come
from nowhere yeah like where'd that come
from yeah what is this yeah
what is uh where where are premises from
what's an idea from it's like
creativity comes from the weirdest part
of your brain that no one knows
how to i mean you there's like you could
have breathing exercises you could do
all sorts of things to try to stimulate
it right but the reality is you can't
even measure it
no you don't know when it's up when it's
down you just know what you're doing if
you're making some cool [ __ ]
yeah well and it's so that's so bizarre
like to think about like you said it's
just really
humans creating something that other
humans [ __ ] with
yeah that's exactly what it is and that
makes you feel good
that's the most there's something there
yeah when you see
like when you're in concert and you see
15 000 people rocking out to your song
right
like that that has got to be a crazy
feeling yeah it is
yeah well whenever you know you're on
the podcast everybody's seeing you
whenever you're kicking somebody
in the face everybody watching there's a
there's a feeling there and it's just
like
oh i realize finally i'm not
actually just one person yeah i
as as like
mithril as it sounds i'm with everybody
you're with us
as as in one moment in time
everybody is there doing the same thing
with the same energy
the same good intention yes it's it's
it's [ __ ] magical you know it's weird
yeah that's what's what you're doing
right you're tapping into some magic
i'm trying but that's what it is if if
you if you think about what kind of
alchemy is involved in making the right
sounds to make people feel different
sure
because with a great song man you're
giving a person a drug
you know there's a there's a dopamine
rush you get goosebumps
a great song will hurt you like you when
you're doing that man you're hitting
that audience
with 15 000 people and they're all
vibing on this thing that you've created
like that's kind of magic
it's [ __ ] magic and that's the
coolest thing
because if you didn't know it existed
you would never believe someone could do
it you're like what are you talking
about if
there's no music at all imagine a world
with no music just animals
right you never figured out how to make
melodies and bars and songs that you
write
down we were just animals right someone
told you hey man there's just i'm going
to make some sounds
and people going to lose their [ __ ]
they're going to be 15 000 people are
going to get
raymond i always think about this too
and this is a weird thought
you know how like there's famous people
throughout history
yeah how the [ __ ] do they know what they
look like
like think about like in like wild west
times
when they see a dude in the bar and he's
like oh you're crazy bill i've seen you
how does that work how did they even
know it was that guy how did they even
know
and then and then even somebody could
say
oh i'm crazy bill oh yeah but then how
do you even believe him
well there's some pop there was imposter
people all up until the internet
you know there's like you you can't be a
fake post malone today
right but you could in 1970 you could
play it off
like stories that people tell
and think if it's the imposter if it's a
real dude
right there's probably a lot of [ __ ]
when it comes to like wild west stories
or think about even 1600s like oh this
dude
it was crazy with a battle axe or
something i saw him
cut like nine dudes in half with one
swing
right but it's the wrong dude right it's
not even
[ __ ] william the the uh
whatever it is i don't know that one
something
no this is a cool what's the cool word
what's a cool name for a dude who swings
battle axes
other than the behemoth the slicer
it was charlie the slicer oh it's
hilarious
you're gonna think there's no way to
tell but just imagine history before
pictures
what are you talking about draw me a
picture this is what the boats would
look like when they would pull how the
[ __ ] do you know
like it was an abstract idea yeah you
were the only way you could
see something was someone how to draw it
for you right
well that's what i love to think like it
used to be like
instagram filters essentially like oh
i'm a rich dude
i want this artist to paint me but make
me
skinny like me like make me rip
yeah yeah yeah maybe a little more
handsome give me a bigger dick in my
statue
i mean imagine if there was like this
one guy you would go to in the
neighborhood and all the ladies were
like you got to go to him he makes her
ass look so perfect
and like that's how they would get their
picture done this dude would paint some
nonsense version of them
this yeah no one knows how do you know
you better
mirrors barely work back then i wasn't
there mirrors were probably terrible
back then
when were mirrors invented they're
looking at [ __ ] through fire
right that's the only way they light any
room up it's fire they have little lamps
everywhere
it's preposterous they have no idea what
they look like it doesn't work no
it doesn't work so imagine this is this
is how ballsy people were
in like the 1400s there were people that
would get in a
boat and travel across a [ __ ] ocean
it would take weeks and weeks and weeks
based on a drawing and some [ __ ] someone
wrote down
yeah it's [ __ ] insane insane you
don't even know where the [ __ ] you are
insane also there's some salty dogs and
some
rap scallions what's what's another
pirate term
dude i was reading about pirates
landlubber the coast of uh south
carolina was it blackbeard
is he with the the big one it just makes
you think like jesus christ like these
are real people that would get
like real famous dudes who'd get in
boats and show up
and just [ __ ] people up and steal all
their [ __ ] they were so famous for doing
that
so crazy and it's so funny you bring up
blackbeard
because i saw somebody had like some
kind of sash
or like uh like like a miss america
like a bandolier oh yeah yeah exactly
and
it was looked like you had a bunch of
like black powder pistols like
you got one shot and then you're out
like
yeah it's so funny that wasn't that long
ago man
does the early 1800s when they came up
with a revolver
the colt came up with the revolver and
they didn't even really put it to use
until the texas rangers
the texas rangers figured out how to uh
there's a guy named it was jack hayes i
think he's the original texas ranger
and basically he was this badass dude
who figured out how to fight the indians
on their turf they were basically like
like the navy seals of the texas
frontier guys who fought against the
comanches and this guy figured out how
to use a revolver
that wasn't that long ago that's like
1840. it
and it's moving so far you know what
they say you know they say
god made man samuel colt made him equal
yeah
that's a [ __ ] great statement that's
what colt invented the revolver
they're the ones who invented the i
think it was a five shot revolver
it was the first time they figured out
how to fight the comanches they would
they would ride on a horse they'd stay
on the horse they didn't get off the
chute and they could shoot five times in
a row and they had a bunch of those
cartridges
so they get the cartridges are already
loaded so they'd take it off
put a new cartridge in fully loaded and
lock it in sure
it was it was the whole wheel yeah the
whole wheel so you can only carry a few
of those with you
crazy it's so bizarre
how much [ __ ] has
evolved to kill each other in since 1840
it's
[ __ ] insane insane and even you think
about even before whenever you had
musk at tears and [ __ ] yeah and you
would just stand in a line
and you would shoot and then a dude
behind you would shoot and everybody's
just shooting
looking right at each other ridiculous
it's it's it
it's the craziest [ __ ] [ __ ]
they fought like that for a long time
man they fought with honor and dignity
like they would show up
blow trumpets when it was time to fight
then they'd go fight each other
they'd all stand in a line yeah two guys
talk you had two guys
walk up and talk yeah go back and then
everybody else would just shoot each
other point blank
like it's it blows my mind
you know it's crazy too there was a lot
of them would uh a lot of them would
they would give up and they would uh
surrender and they would
hand the man their sword and they would
accept it and shake their hand
they had like weird rules of combat that
everybody sort of adhered to back then
it's very strange to read about
it's it's different it's different as
[ __ ] but
it's not that long ago that's what's
crazy it's like the best you could do is
shoot someone with a musket or a cannon
right just a couple hundred years ago
right that's i mean that's
manageable it's it's it's nuclear
weapons aren't managed
yet now now it's like one nuclear bomb
ruined your whole day
yeah that's not manageable at all
it's it's awful tyler tyler and ziggy
are looking down at us right now
my aunt those are like that's why
they're here i agree
i agree wholeheartedly i think they're
like these dummies
are going to do something stupid if
aliens are real i'm not 100 convinced
that i'm probably like 90 convinced but
if they are real
i leave in the room for [ __ ] it's
like jamie get a picture of your shirt
show everybody this
it's a ufo it says can they see it
believe that
that's a dope shirt that's a saucer if
i've ever seen one
i think if they're if they're here
they're not gonna let us that's what i
think
well that's where i think they're gonna
swoop in and go hey hey hey
well this [ __ ] i'm 25 right
i can't speak on anything but just
looking from
past experience and you know there's
like
drawings like even in the mona lisa
there's a
weird thing or whatever in the
background and [ __ ]
but there's a spike
it's a spike in like because it's
getting
pretty weird here the spike they think
it's
hard to tell because sometimes when
people talk about ufos a bunch of other
people
hallucinate or lie like there's a lot of
that
right so every time there's a real legit
ufo you get a bunch of nut
just nut cases who just want to tell
crazy [ __ ] about being taken and i see
more ships
i mean you've seen i never know yeah
would you say what'd it look like
i was in i was probably 16
i was at in upstate new york
and uh it would just stay there so i
whoa let me precursor this my aunt and
uncle were very strict and we had to go
to bed at a very strict deadline
probably 10 p.m and
i was looking out the window with my
cousin
and it's just a light that just stays
there
and then just [ __ ] goes off i mean
you
it just you can't explain it
well if you're seven you're 17 at the
time 16 16
how uh probably how strong is this
memory when you're like looking at it
when you're trying to remember medium
medium yeah yeah but i mean there's
something there for sure something took
off and did something that didn't make
sense to you for sure
and then in utah i mean their [ __ ]
happens all the time i mean even here in
l.a
i can't tell you how many times because
i used to live in tarzana
so there was like
a balcony here and it looked kind of
like
it sounds corny but like a classic like
force field whenever you think of a
force field
and it just kind of goes like this and
it's kind of like a dome
in a circular shape
and it just goes like this and goes back
in
whoa in tarzana
looking down at the [ __ ] city and i'm
like how did no one else see this
they might have but i was there with
like [ __ ] four other people and they
saw two
the thing about unique events
is if a unique event happens and it
never happens again it's hard to
remember
it's hard to be sure what you saw it's
hard
but if aliens are visiting us like how
often are they doing it
like unique events would probably be
what it would be right it'd be like
occasionally
right once every six months someone sees
one somewhere
but they're here all the time they
probably just know how to evade
detection
i mean it just if something can travel
here from another planet
it's going to be able to know yeah when
they're being watched and when they're
not being watched so it's not going to
be hard that's why you got to wonder if
it's like
intentional i think there's enough talk
about it now that we're probably going
to find out
what it is in our lifetime i never would
think that before i think the government
withheld information for whatever reason
maybe they think people are scared
maybe they think it's a threat to govern
to you know
the national security to have a bunch of
people worried that aliens are flying
around us all the time there's nothing
we can do about it
maybe they like had a conversation and
they thought maybe it'd be better to
keep people in the quiet or keep them in
the dark so that they don't freak out
because there's nothing we can do about
it anyway if we just tell them
that there's aliens that are visiting us
all the time right it's that's not going
to be good they're not going to pay
attention to taxes and
mortgage rates and the stock market
they're going to care about uranium and
they're [ __ ] like this
they're around us all the time they're
gonna be people are gonna freak out
so i think like little drops like this
the recent one they said
were they yeah what did the pentagon
just say yeah literally like
two [ __ ] days ago they've recovered
crafts that are not from this world
not made on earth not made on earth not
made on earth
they're basically saying we don't know
what the [ __ ] it is but we didn't make
it
that's bananas and i think that's going
to lead to
more and more information coming out
about it where we're going to
try to get a sense of understanding like
how long have they known this
you know how much of like all that
roswell new mexico [ __ ] was true
like tell us what was going on and at
backtracking
you got to wonder if like oh we've been
hiding this the whole time
or this is the first time for real
that we don't know this is what i like
to think i like to think that the people
that are in charge
at the pentagon are patriots and they
realize it's probably better
especially when you're dealing with the
united states in this kind of turmoil
that they're in right now
it's crazy between racial turmoil and
turmoil with the police and
turmoil with uh people uh protesting in
cities and
blocking traffic there's so much crazy
turmoil they'd be like no one's even
gonna notice now just let it
say it now to say yeah we got ufos like
everything is so crazy the new cycle of
any crazy story like this is only a few
days
and then people forget well or
it's just people already know
and it's just normalization or and you
think about movies
as just normalizing you to the idea that
i can even like the canadian i
don't quote me on this but a canadian
someone in office was like there's like
seven species of aliens
in the u.s government
[Laughter]
it would be crazy if it was true that's
you know
tommy lee jones and will do you all
remember that all along
yeah check that out please fact check
that out see a loony person though
i have no idea see people can get
elected and still be crazy
that's probably certain that's a problem
you know
just because like when you hear about
someone having like a really high
profile job
and they say something crazy it doesn't
mean they're not crazy just because
they're the prime minister of some
[ __ ] country they could be out of
their mind
what do we got close to that
how close
former defense minister claims that
aliens are real apparently there is a
humanoid-esque
race of aliens called the tall whites
living among us huh
what
[Laughter]
that's crazy [ __ ] yeah that is crazy
[ __ ]
the thing is is that guy nuts like what
else does he believe in you know how
how does he feel about ghosts right do
you believe in ghosts
how often i don't not believe i don't
not believe in ghosts
i've never experienced a ghost ghosts
are real
but i can't i can't explain it they
might be they might be real
but i don't know if it's a ghost here's
the thing about ghosts
there's so many stories of them right
there's so many right
now is it because people are just scared
and their [ __ ]
senses are on heightened alert and they
see things that aren't really there
that could be it because when it's dark
out
and you're tired and you're moving
through the hallway first of all you
might be half asleep anyway
but you hear things you get scared your
senses get really heightened
and maybe you might see something that's
not even really there right it's just
your
your own brain and your paranoia [ __ ]
with you because it's always happening
at night
under low light conditions it's always
weird things that are fleeting and then
they're gone
but it's not always yourself it's not
always in the night it's always in the
dark though right
never like at the beach there's a ghost
at the beginning i don't know there
might be ghosts at the beach
it depends there's no
your house is just as haunted in the day
as it is at night
but why not the beach listen the beach
at night is scary
the beach during the day not scary at
all if you're a girl and you're walking
on the beach at night that's a [ __ ]
dangerous place to be
right there's a lot of psychos out there
and serial killers and creeps
and rapists you're just walking on that
beach by yourself that's scary
at night right but in the day it's
awesome the day you're just walking on
the beach
i'm not a beach guy anyways i'm a
mountain guy
there might be some more creepy guys in
the mountains that's another one
but they're they're more sparse they're
more than scary in the world but i'm
saying
your house is just as this place this
building
is just as haunted in the daytime as it
is at nighttime
i don't think this one's haunted i've
been here at night
here's an argument for something being
haunted the comedy the comedy store in
hollywood
because it used to be cyros nightclub it
used to be owned by bugsy siegel
and apparently the word is they killed a
bunch of [ __ ] people there
right and almost everyone that i know
that works there everyone who's
managed it works there a long time they
have some weird [ __ ] happen to them
weird [ __ ] like they they see someone in
the kitchen
and they go to say something to them
they turn around and then they turn back
again the person's gone
right weird [ __ ] right like old friends
you haven't seen
forever wandering through the hallway
and they go up the stairs and you can't
find them there's like a bunch of
stories like that
now granted there's a lot of people
who've done a lot of drugs at the comedy
store right
that has to be factored in right but
there's so many
stories worldwide of ghosts i don't
think it's impossible
to i think it's possible that
things leave a memory right like maybe
you hate someone so
much like you you leave a memory on the
space like that's a stone type theory
yeah the what stone tape yeah
stone tape yeah what is that that the
energy
of a life is like left
on
material [ __ ] like the bricks on the
wall yeah
or the curtain here right you know and
that's like
i don't know if that's a stone tape
theory don't quote me on don't quote me
on that
can you look up the can you look up the
stone tape theory for me
stone tape but it's well
because i'm i'm friends with zach
baggins from ghost adventures right
and it's like did he ever take you to a
haunted house we did
we did a whole episode you should check
it out
it's terrifying
it's terrifying man in his museum
so apparently there's a thing called the
dybbuk box
which is a one of the most
haunted items in the world
apparently and
he wanted so we took the glass case
off of the dybbuk box which is in his
museum in vegas
and he thought it was a sick ass idea to
put the ashes of a lady who died
while she was possessed on top whoa
and then i was
my plane almost crashed i was in a car
accident
my house got robbed and i had bite marks
on my arm
and he
hit the wall like like i've never seen
someone in fear so hard as whenever he
touched it and
it's it's i don't know if it's someone
who's dead or if it's a demon or if it's
[ __ ] something dimensional
but it's something there that
goes bump in the night i suppose
stone tape theory what is that here it
is haunted rocks the stone tape theory
the stone
tape theory is frequently used as a
sciencey-sounding quasi-explanation to
explain amateur
to explain hauntings okay okay
investigators that's what i'm two for
two
two mi two for two experiences of images
sound and apparitions that do not
interact directly with people instead
they play out like a movie or recording
that's the most commonly termed residual
haunting see this is what i was saying
like
two for two by the way ladies and
gentlemen congratulations
nailed it when you uh think about like
an alien sighting like if you saw an
alien they never saw one again for the
rest of your life right you would be you
it would [ __ ] with your memory
even if the alien was real if a saucer
emerged in front of you and then took
off that's the same thing with a ghost
like if you saw a [ __ ] ghost if you
walked into your basement to go get
a screw for something and you turned and
you saw an apparition of a woman
right who's like staring you down did
you ever see that guamo del toro movie
about the lady who's a ghost who adopts
kids
no dude it's a dark movie
what is it called mother what is it
called it's
[ __ ] creepy
it's cool do you like horror movies i
love them me too i love it i'm a dirty
little [ __ ] i love horror movies
i think it's called mama mama yes that's
it oh
is that that's not with two swedish kids
right
um i don't have kisses two sons
did you see this no she has two kids no
i haven't seen that she's um
she well i don't want to give it away i
don't give the story away but
it's crazy she finds these kids in the
woods and raises them and she's a ghost
and it's a [ __ ]
terrifying moment she's a ghost yes
and so that's the kids they find the
kids i can't tell you anymore
spoiler alert i can't tell you anymore
no you know she's a ghost from the very
beginning
okay okay good yeah this is terrifying
dude
it's [ __ ] horrifying it's a
terrifying movie well you get the best
of both worlds right you get a creepy
like mom style and then you get creepy
kids which are like both the double
terrifying what's the movie i can't say
anymore without
um without spoiler alert there's a
i think it may be called it might become
so it's two kids it might be swedish or
um like norwegian or something
is it the vampire movie no there's a
little there's a vampire movie a foreign
vampire movie
is it let the right one in i think it is
or is that the american version of it
let the right one in is a scary movie
that's a scary movie right
that's a vampire movie about vampire
kids right yeah
yeah see the thing about a ghost
is if you saw one and it was if they're
just real every now and then
you saw one and it was right in front of
you you're in the woods
you're going to walk your dog and you
see some old man with no legs
floating in front of that's the one good
night mommy yeah
good night mommy what's this one about i
don't know
same kind of deal explosion spoiler
alert oh
jesus christ did you see something good
yeah i missed this scary lady in the
corner check that [ __ ] out
i'm scared but you see him in the woods
yeah
please oh yeah if you saw some
some apparition in the woods and then
you never saw it again for the rest of
your life it doesn't mean it wasn't real
right just means it's really rare that
that happens like that's the thing about
a unique event like
imagine if you're an aunt your whole
[ __ ] life right all you've ever known
is this handheld everybody's chilling
working every day chopping up leaves
going out and getting
popcorn or whatever [ __ ] it finds and
then one day some person comes along
like post malone just stomps the [ __ ]
out of that ant hill
sure till that moment all that thing has
ever known was that
that ant hill never even knew that it
was possible for something that could
cause it's
been alive for a couple weeks and during
that couple weeks no one's ever stomped
on the anthill
but then it happens and then you realize
that there's no pattern to these things
anything can happen
like if you're if you're a person aliens
can land
you can land on the white house law
tomorrow and take over the world
and there's nothing we can do about it
like that could be our new normal
okay [ __ ] masks the new normal is
there's alien spaceships that hover over
every city and they tell you what to do
and you have to work for them now
forever to the
argument we're smarter than ants
yes we are but we're in comparison
probably dumber
than aliens are like we're dumber in
comparison to aliens
than ants are to people well that's
right you like
all these celestial sightings yeah i
mean this is all
uh spitballing here but it could be
possible right
celestial sightings
documented throughout history history
you
hey i just made a fire this is dope
right fire is cool but what the [ __ ] is
that that has to be
yeah god like man has always looked up
for answers it's true and so that's
that's that's why it's a scary thing
because do they want to hurt us or do
they
are they did we come from them i don't
think it's impossible
i don't think it's impossible that we're
a product of genetic manipulation i
don't know if we are
i know we're definitely primates we're
just play things maybe
we just look so different than every
other monkey all the other monkeys are
covered in hair
this is this weird semi-hairless monkey
you know who knows how to use
electronics who knows how to send
video through this you know the anunnaki
yes
yes yes
my my yeah if lou is here i got a great
friend lou shout out to lou he would
talk about this whole deal about this to
an actual archaeologist yesterday or the
nephilim
yeah the nephilim or the anunnaki from
planet nibiru all that zechariah's hitch
and stuff
you ever read those books no sir the
books are weird man you know what's
weird
like there's stuff that he was saying
in like i believe it was like the 1970s
where he was deciphering
these texts and one of the things that
he said is
this is the craziest one of all humans
were genetically engineered
from lower primates and they were used
to harm
to harvest gold and that the anunnaki
needed gold because gold is very
plentiful here
right and very hard to find very rare
on their planet right and they
engineered humans to mine that's why
people love gold so much
right if you think about like the
usefulness of gold right gold isn't even
remotely it's unless you're making
electronics
like gold's not the best metal like why
is it so valuable because it's pretty
well it's not even the prettiest [ __ ]
like rubies are prettier than gold
emeralds are pretty then gold why is
gold so goddamn expensive but where does
diamonds fit in
it's a good question probably just
someone tricked a chick they're thinking
it was great
i was reading about like yeah that's
what there's like
one movie she had a diamond and then
booty
let me finish what i'm saying because
this is where it gets weird they said
that they needed it
to hang in their atmosphere to protect
them from the sun
because they were losing their
atmosphere well we're losing our
atmosphere
and one of the things that scientists
have uh suggested is
hanging reflective particles above
above the earth like putting them in
orbit all like a reflective
dust in orbit so that it would mute out
some of the effects of the sun
so what they suggested what he was
saying
in 1978 is what they suggested in like
2018
right so when they're talking about how
to fix some of the global warming issues
they were literally saying some of the
stuff that was in this book
that he was reading you know he's
deciphering the
these ancient sumerian texts from six
thousand years ago
no [ __ ] yeah i don't know i was i don't
know his interpretation where did
he get it from he is
just a guy who's a linguist who studies
these ancient languages
and and reinterprets them but it's very
highly in dispute
that's the problem like you are not you
are you or i we're not going to figure
it out
we're not going to know who's right
right it's too complicated right but
there's a website called sitchin is
wrong.com and if you go there refutes
all of his cr i don't know who's right
or who's wrong
but it's interesting to see the argument
but again
what the whatever the [ __ ] was going on
back then six thousand years ago
whatever was going on they were writing
about some wacky [ __ ]
right right you know they were and is
that the shrooms or is that
is it contact yeah you know is that's
it's not impossible they we could have
easily been contacted
by some other life form that's similar
to us but that's
a million years advanced right have been
contacted all throughout history
right yeah up until 1860 whatever the
[ __ ] it was all you would have is a
drawing and a story
imagine that how famous people
who the [ __ ] knows but now
if you look at the last 200 years
it has accelerated like a [ __ ]
and there's so much like
200 years ago people would look at
uh the bronco or anything like that and
be like what the [ __ ]
yeah what is that it happened so quick
it's happening so quick right now i mean
they that spacex thing they've already
they've
figured out how to get something to fly
into the sky and then bring it back and
land it
it's insane yeah we are in a weird
[ __ ] time and if the aliens come
right now it's probably the best time to
come we're gonna be the most relaxed
about it
no one's been able to work for six
months yeah i feel like everybody's oh
what's
people are scared to shake hands
terrified
are you gonna say hi are you the aliens
are you gonna grab your
bow oh i'm gonna say hi for sure i'm not
stupid
they could come here disintegration
yeah i'm not even interested in kicking
someone's ass from another dimension
i just want to say hi tell me what's up
tell me what's actually i want to have
an alien on the podcast you imagine i
could call it
tyler three foot tall 40 pound
dude with a giant bulbous head and like
antenna like fingers and he's explaining
how they traverse spaceship
you imagine they're making sounds and
you
interpret those sounds no matter what
language you're in all over the world
you instantaneously interpret
it through your brain you wouldn't be
able to hear them if they would do it
through a podcast
they would hit you with some sound
that's so complex you would understand
exactly what they're saying even though
you don't know the language
and everybody would be like what in the
[ __ ] is going on oh my god there's an
alien on the jre
and that's what it would be me talking
to some alien
they better they better give you some
more goddamn money
i think that's the least of our problems
when the aliens come that [ __ ] is going
to be wacky but that's when we need gold
yeah we're going to be gold miners again
folks we're going to look for some
sturdy person with a wide back
that's that's what's going to be
valuable but i mean good enough to mine
gold i don't know
you imagine if that's life in the future
they come down and go you get two
choices
eat one we eat you two you mind gold for
us
are they eating stay alive why not why
wouldn't they eat us they'd be like
listen you guys are just protein you're
[ __ ] they probably
eat clouds yeah or like energy they
probably just eat energy
yeah they maybe they just exist in some
sort of uh like uh dude they're probably
not even
[ __ ] material probably they're
probably just [ __ ]
ethereal well maybe they figured out a
way to make
life so maybe they figured out a way
how to make life where you can transfer
your consciousness in some eternal
mechanical thing this is what um
there's this uh oh my god i can't
remember his name uh ray kurzweil
sorry uh he's a guy that's upset he's a
scientist he's an inventor he's got like
a hundred patents genius guy
uh maybe not a hundred but a lot um and
he
is obsessed with downloading his
consciousness into a computer
he's obsessed with the idea of
technology reaching a point where you
could replicate
uh a human being in in a way where you
will never die your consciousness will
actually transmit to
some sort of a computer or an artificial
body
or another body that's they've
genetically engineered
and he believes this is like he's saying
you have to look at the exponential rate
of technology
right now that doesn't make any sense
right but if you go 10 years from now
10 years is going to the 10 years time
is going to be like 100 years of
progress
like you said exponentially snowballing
10 years after that a thousand years
right progress like 20 years from now i
don't know if those are the right
numbers
but 20 years from now or somewhere in
that range we could be looking at
artificial life
we could be 30 years from now we could
be looking at fake people they're
already cloning
goats yeah they've done sheep yeah
dolly the sheep yeah i bet they're
cloning people
100 percent 100 100 you don't think
russia
is cloning people right now you don't
think china's cloning people right now
why wouldn't they
i think we're cloning people well if you
think of the people that do
that treat human beings with the least
amount of respect
if those like if you think the way they
treat their citizens
those people are likely to clone people
they're not going to give a [ __ ]
they're going to want to give a [ __ ]
quick quick to the jump yeah
we don't give a [ __ ] i don't think
anybody
it's it's a matter of
it does honestly feel like oh
everybody's just a gold miner
in a way because we're mining technology
everybody i mean
even even you sitting on your phone
you're
contributing 100 yeah and then they're
learning and you want a new phone you
want a new phone next year so you work
hard so you can buy that new phone
right and you want to test this it's got
that big old electronic screen it's a
car
yeah and the whole machine i wouldn't
can i have a
one of your beard hairs um i'm working
on something at home i could give you
some i'll squeeze them later i can't
pluck them
they're not big enough to i'm not i'm
working on my cloning device
it doesn't work necessarily it might
work dude if it works let me know if
there's a little me running around i
tell them a lot of [ __ ] i got wrong
[Laughter]
kicking everybody i feel like dude you
got to calm down
calm down son but like i think genetic
engineering they've already definitely
done that they've figured out how to
um i think it was china that did some
sort of crispr experiment on people's
dna
that figured out how to make them immune
from aids but also simultaneously made
them smarter
so made them immune to hiv i'm pretty
sure that's what it was what's a crisp
crisp oh crisper some gene editing tool
i don't know what the
it's an acronym right i don't know what
it stands for
but it's um it's a new gene editing tool
that they've discovered over the last
few years
they understand genes better because i
believe because of bacteria i'm sure i'm
[ __ ] this up
but they figured out how to make a tool
that allows you to edit
genes here it is clustered regular
regularly interspaced short
palindromic repeats that's crispr that's
what it stands for it's a family of dna
sequences
found in the genomes of uh
prokaryote prokaryote organisms such as
bacteria and archi
archaea archie archaea
these sequences are derived from dna
fragments of
bacterial fog this is
[Laughter]
phages that had previously infected the
pro
prokaryote oh boy ah so i know exactly
what you're talking about
let me try so this gene editing tool
whatever the [ __ ] that means what the
[ __ ] what is this tool
they can edit genes and they're in the
process with the computer it'll show you
right how to
how they do it there it's it's like i
don't know understand the process
but i know that they have a process i
don't know what it's saying
is this in a computer what is that
saying the cas9 protein forms a complex
forms a complex with the guide rna
in a cell the complex attaches to a
matching
genomic dna sequence adjacent to a
spacer yellow segment
the cat yeah what am i saying okay no
that's the yellow segment but you know
what i'm saying
i do but do you know what i'm saying
like i'm reading this and i don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm saying one that's
right
it's too complicated for a [ __ ] like me
it's too complicated
i want to know what the tool is is it
like a wrench
or is it like a [ __ ] computer i don't
know what the [ __ ] it is
it's probably a computer oh it's a fork
yeah that's a dude that's the dude right
this is the guy
it's just a robot hand it's a dude with
tweezers and a [ __ ] hot dog
it leaves a lot of room for error i just
i wonder like what other countries are
doing
what kind of crazy [ __ ] they're trying
if they're they're trying to create new
human super humans
they're going to do it someone's going
to do it it's going to be us or it's
going to be them
someone is going to create superhumans
i'm not saying it's a good idea
i'm just looking at the the laws of
improvement i don't think that's a real
thing
but if it was the law of improvement
would state that if something's possible
if something's possible someone's going
to make it happen when we we detonated
two nuclear bombs we could have just
one was we everybody got the point right
yeah why they do it twice display i
suppose
right well someone could do that with
super people yeah like that could happen
it could happen quick
he should be a ufc fighter well they
might be
the new aliens when you get to ufc
fighters super people
super people might be a new species if
someone could really get a hold of a
crisper and create like a thor
create like a like a legitimate
superhuman person
and you could just develop a whole race
of those it would just be like instant
game over people aren't people anymore
how long does that take i don't know how
long it would take do they have to grow
from baby to
behind man these are freaks i don't
think so that's the thing
they just come out like i think they
just works in lord
[Music]
they come out at like orcs and lord of
the rings where they just cut the
pus and then the [ __ ] they come
piling out of them
and he's just like i'm gonna kill
[ __ ] uh
is that how the orcs were born yeah
you've never seen charoman
yeah in the pit of helms deep
those are great [ __ ] movies man
incredible those orcs were the scariest
[ __ ] ever
also if you watched three if you watch
three it's 12 hours
you could take a half a day watching the
ranks
it's the best yeah those lord of the
rings movies man
come on those orcs and those
goblins they were the scariest [ __ ]
the goblins were scary
oh you ever heard a necro goblicon no
it's like a metal band but the lead
singer
is a goblin
it's incredible can you pull up a
picture of the lead singer
of necrogoblicon
dude this is that's them dude it's
[ __ ] incredible
that's easy he reminds me of he reminds
me of the goblin that
tortures frodo look at his face holy
[ __ ]
oh my god that's amazing this is just
hang on a second
imagine i like his friends hold on a
second back up a little bit imagine
if that's really a goblin you imagine if
a goblin became a rock star and
everybody thought it was cute
but it really was a [ __ ] goblin you
need to watch the video bro the makeup's
amazing he never takes it off
and it's a real [ __ ] goblet real
goblin well that's the whole deal like
the his biggest song is like he has a
normal job and he has a crush on this
girl
oh my god but she's in love with this
like douchebag
from the office oh my god is it blowing
powder on people what is happening here
i've never seen this video
dude just imagine if that was real
because of an
alien comes down like if with cg is
goblins
they could be why do we think they're
gonna look cute why couldn't they be
ugly looking
aliens octopus-looking monsters they
could be anything
right yeah that's a halo you ever play
halo
i have you think about you know arbiter
what is arbiter he's uh one of the
characters
yeah he's like the alien like the alien
guys
so they have fingers like this and
that's why
all their guns are like this right okay
but who's to say that aliens don't
control their guns with like
their booty hole or something weird why
does it have to be with their hands
aliens can control their guns with
whatever
appendage they had good point
aliens are weird i think the real thing
would
it would come from me how
how are they manipulating matter to make
things right or do they even need to do
they need to right
can they do things with their mind that
we can't imagine
right is it possible to if it's possible
to make noise
and you can hear noise what is that it's
just some invisible [ __ ] flying through
the air
i'm saying it to you you understand what
i'm saying just flies through the air
and hits you
why do we think that that's the only
thing that's possible there could be
some really
weird abilities that things have to
manipulate matter that maybe evolve over
hundreds of thousands of years
yeah who knows
who knows i'm gonna hit you with my
[ __ ] booty hole gun and
destroy a [ __ ] block maybe it's like
super normal for aliens like pee on each
other
the way dogs do you know
maybe aliens just walk up and just piss
on each other all the time
who knows who [ __ ] knows who knows
but you know
all we can do is just sit and drink beer
until until
that's it i'm amazed that they if they
really did have ufos this whole time
that they kept it such a good secret
pretty incredible like i don't want to
encourage that kind of behavior
but i gotta say i'm impressed right if
the government really kept their [ __ ]
mouth shut for that long
like no new government is not these are
like those
old school vietnam vets with [ __ ]
craggy skin and tough guy voices right
those are the ones that are still left
millennials that take those positions
we're gonna have a real hard time
keeping secrets
right it's not gonna be the same it's
not
no i mean you they're not gonna keep any
secrets
how do you feel about the battle of los
angeles
the battle of los angeles yeah wherever
there there was pictures in the paper
and [ __ ] and it's just spotlights and we
were shooting at this thing
oh right was that like overall
yeah real old like the 50s or something
yeah yeah
who the [ __ ] knows what that was man
what the [ __ ] is that
and then we shot at it and it wouldn't
go down and
you know because they see that
who knows you got it's either two things
it's either they know
and they're hiding it or it's something
earthly
terrestrial yeah
and people just interpret it as
yeah look at there it is search lights
and anti-aircraft guns
they were shooting at this [ __ ] calm
sky during alarm what year is that jamie
1942 so what year did oppenheimer first
detonate the bomb i know the manhattan
project was already in operation by 42
but had they
detonated the first bomb yet
tests are the actual the actual first
test let me check
okay i bet it was around that time a
couple years later maybe
i bet in that in that time period when
human beings start in a race to try to
split the atom
that's what i bet the aliens like hey
hey hey we got a live one yeah we got a
live one over here these
[ __ ] figured it out yeah the
1940s they were all doing that [ __ ]
right
three years later three years later yeah
so they were probably working on it back
then
and the aliens were probably well aware
that there was a race going on
and they probably visited that's what i
would do if i had
uh like like a planet like imagine if
you're
a a researcher and you have a whole
planet
and on this planet they've lived for
millions and millions of years but the
most advanced thing is like a monkey
person
you know like an australopithecus or
something and they go listen
we know where this is going it's going
to take a long time they might not even
make it they might get wiped out by a
volcano let's just [ __ ] sprinkle a
little bit of us in them
get that crisper working manipulate the
dna
or the little tongs with the hot dog the
hot dog tongs
splice it in and make some new people
what happened to the dinosaurs
joe asteroid yeah that hit the yucatan
they know when they
know where there's there's something
called uh i think it's called iridium
and it it's really rare on earth and
really common in space
and there's a thick layer of it around
65 million years ago and it's just
giant crater in the yucatan that's what
killed all the dinosaurs
first most likely most likely there's
some other theories about uh
how long they lasted which ones died off
which one
like like alex alligators those
[ __ ]
alligators are here right now right bro
one eight a kid at disneyland a couple
years back
no [ __ ] it was the year before i was
there disney world
not disneyland disney world's the
florida one ate a kid yeah a
two-year-old kid
snatched him up jesus horrible horrible
playing near the water in this [ __ ]
dinosaur and
imagine you take your kid at disney
world well it's gonna be safe for sure
we're at disney world yeah they've done
a great job making sure there's not
monsters living in the pond
yeah nope no there's monsters in that
pond
[ __ ] alligator came out and ate their
kid look at this [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] that's the one
this is a different one
this one i was like they have video of
this bro these people are standing just
a few feet away from a goddamn dinosaur
with a brain the size of a quarter
that thing doesn't give a [ __ ] about you
or your babies or your kids or
you're just lucky you're lucky that
dinosaur doesn't just the tail is the
size of a human
yeah it's so they're so big and that's
not even a huge one
there's there's a video one in florida
walking across a golf court it's 15 feet
long
and you see it and these guys are in awe
they're like what the [ __ ]
they're out there playing golf and a
legitimate dinosaur walks by
15 foot long alligator it's so
big it's so big dude look at it it's
like look at it look at that thing look
at that thing is this
yes holy christ holy christ look how big
that
is on the golf course bro look how big
it is
look at the size of that thing holy [ __ ]
man
your ball struck my foot holy [ __ ] that
thing's so big
i'll see you in the parking lot
what's the billy madison quote
or happy gilmore that's what it is oh
the alligator ate his hand
carl weathers it's [ __ ] crazy how
crazy is that
you're out there living in florida you
live with me that's a dinosaur
that's a real legit dinosaur you think
about it too it's so interesting to
think about
like even in florida but in australia
the spiders the house spiders like i see
a spider he's like this big
i'm like okay fine
in australia the average spider is like
this [ __ ] big
yeah what are you gonna do terrifying
creatures over there
there's brown snakes and [ __ ] my
australian friend adam greentree he's
always trying to get me to go out there
go camping with him like get the [ __ ]
out of here
no he goes hunting i'm not starting look
at that thing
look at that thing no
what the [ __ ] no no no so much protein
if yeah you're hungry is that a huntsman
yeah jesus christ look at that thing
that's so big australia's just buck wild
man
there's it's so bizarre to think like
all and you've seen the there's big-ass
grasshoppers
that are like this big
locust man terrifying
you know i i didn't find out until a few
years ago yeah look at that [ __ ]
what is that dude he's eating a full
carrot like an infant
like a toddler he's eating a carrot like
a [ __ ] toddler
that's insane it's like he's screaming
through a traffic cone
also if i saw a centipede i would die oh
my gosh look at the size of that
look at that butterfly thing moth
motts are like the ugly butterflies true
it's really the same thing how come why
is one of those pretty and what happens
with the [ __ ] swat
every chance yeah what because we value
beauty look at that
look at that crazy if i saw that i would
run away
bro you ever seen a centipede eat a
mouse no do you want to
probably see find the centipede eats a
mouse
i didn't know they did this man
i never would have thought that thing
was a monster i thought it was just a
bug probably
it's little bugs no eats about you just
saw a grasshopper eat a carrot
like a [ __ ] four-year-old it's crazy
that's a four pound grasshopper look at
this
look at this centipede attacking this
match oh [ __ ] bro they're predatory
like alien like a movie that's like the
movie alien
holy look at this [ __ ] it's biting into
the background oh this is a sign
of them and killing it dude it's more
than sad
that's an alien what is
into the body oh my god take that off of
the camera bro
imagine holy [ __ ] that's why you need to
learn jiu jitsu
for centerpieces need to learn jiu jitsu
you need to you need to figure out how
to well that's your next venture move
that's a nice jiu-jitsu class don't let
them get your back
but that's not good it's your back my
cat's killed two mice
in my house your cats are murderers
every cat's murder
there's no doubt about that but if if
the mice knew jujitsu maybe
my cat would have died cat is so big cat
is big
they don't have a chance but the
centipede is not that much bigger than
the mouse
or it's smaller than the mouse really
cat is big mice
is small what we got to worry about is
bugs because bugs are small
but that's what nature did to them they
made them like
invulnerable but small so we could
squash them
but if they were big we'd be so [ __ ]
those murder hornets remember they were
trying to scare us with those
that was it was right during the covid
like you know you saw
tiger king and then murder haunted but
then no but then
the honeybee figured out how to vibrate
yeah
all around it and kill it with heat
isn't that crazy
that's crazy crazy how did they figure
that out
and how do they know how to work
together to overheat the
utah is the hive state murder wasp utah
is the hive state so
bees are smart as [ __ ] yeah they're
weirdly smart
weirdly smart there's something
connected to bees
and aliens well for how come they all
know how to make that [ __ ] hive
there's no classes they just come out
knowing like
i can go come on man imagine all over
the world
this one being knows exactly the kind of
shape to make
and makes it with like what's it using
how do
what creates that wax it's like using
what they get it's using what they get
from
plants right is it pollen that makes the
stuff that
they use for wax is that what they get
or is it an excretion from their own
excretion so they eat then they make
this excretion and then they they
literally build a house with their own
spit
and then we eat it yeah it's delicious
honeycomb
it's very good never have i ever had it
i'm not a big honey guy no
are you into sweet and low no
you you're an aspartame or a real sugar
guy
i like the coke with real sugar real
sugar coke's the best
that's true and there's an added benefit
of knowing it's killing your body
the diet coke you can pretend you're
healthy i'm having a diet coke
this is basically like pepsi max that is
not water [ __ ]
it doesn't there's nothing about that
that's water
this is water for me you know
what do you say why don't you crack that
one open
i will let's really get into it let's
get down to the real nitty gritty we got
pretty into it man
we're with aliens making you talking
about eating
poop yes yeah you know
that's the crazy thing is we need bees
to make other plants like can you find
out about pollination you're like what
like that's how it's done it's done
through the b the b gets it on their
body and then they go to another plant
and it pollinates it
that's bananas what a stupid system and
there's a there is a matriarchy
oh yeah for sure there's one boss
yup queen [ __ ] that's crazy
it's just like humans essentially
yeah well in a way well it's not though
it's like
some it's here's like this is the thing
about bees
they're small so we love them
but if they were big they would be our
biggest enemy ever
that would be the most terrifying thing
on the planet is a horse-sized bee
and then imagine like enormous
huge colonies of horse-sized bees
that come out of the mountains like
demons just
come in sound like a freaking helicopter
people up yeah
do what those japanese hornets do where
they cut those beehives head those uh
honeybees heads off imagine if there's
something out there doing that there's
bees cutting other bees heads off
oh yeah that's what these murder hornets
do they they climb on top of the back of
the honey bee and they bite their head
off
yeah but then honey bee strength in
numbers that's the strength
i got but guess what they don't always
win it doesn't always work out sometimes
it's a lot of times [ __ ] get
their heads cut off dude there's a
terrifying one that if it was a horror
movie like if you were a honeybee it
would be the worst
like conan the barbarian movie ever yeah
the most
brutal they swarm in and these
murder hornets grab a hold of these
honeybees and just chop their heads off
and they're trying to get in i think to
get to the uh
i think they want did they what do they
want the eggs
this looks like what are they trying to
get music video bro it's whatsapp
i think they're just [ __ ] i don't
know they're just [ __ ]
but look how they do it they cut their
[ __ ] heads off man it's horrific
they're so much bigger and they just run
up on these honeybees and cut their
heads off
how do they cut them off with those
clippers incisors yeah see those
front clippers there's lateral they just
grab them and chop them up man it's
horrific
they just tear them apart with their
face so this is there's these weird
look those are all dead honeybees and
these weird wars that go on
with these uh murder hornets and
honeybees how do you film this do you
know what's going to happen like do they
set the fight
they did they totally set those [ __ ]
dude it looks like a [ __ ]
tony hawk skate video this looks like a
very 90s
video jamie that's a really good
question like do you think that this is
like a
murder for hire scene they need it's
just not filming for me
let the bees let the horns go they need
a fisheye
they need a fish look at what's going on
here you got these hornington you have
murdered by this is a horror movie for
bees like look around back there those
are all bee bodies
good transition there cut these i mean
if if that's what we're like maybe they
did set this up maybe they brought in
murder hornets to an active honeybee
colony i know bodies noteless bodies
the comb oh the comb yeah i know how'd
they figure that out it's
perfect it's always like that too it's
not like one guy like bro
i'm going to have a [ __ ] double xl
eight edges yeah no one has cones like
you know like some wheels on cars that
are just so big
there's no cone like that they're all
the same
you all know how to do it all over the
world too it's a weird animal
we're just lucky that little thing is
that that size
that [ __ ] was big german
shepherd-sized bees
let's go back let's go back to the
monolithic period
they're probably bees [ __ ] a foot
long
let's find out what was the biggest bee
in history
you say a foot long i say you're
probably right i say footlong
i agree with you i bet you dinosaur time
just [ __ ] were about that big that
makes sense
maybe even bigger i'm gonna go foot and
a half [ __ ] it i'll go foot in a half
what do you think jamie the first result
was not correct
it gave me something that was actually
alive recently they thought was extinct
so that's not oh
but let's take a guess now while we're
uh
i'd say 11 inches i'd say a foot and a
half what do you say
that sounds so big i know they're but
everything's bigger
yeah 17 inches is pretty big i mean
18 inches five six inches that's pretty
big
yeah inch and a half i say 11.
it's totally possible though there was
giant [ __ ] bugs back then 18 inches
ain't [ __ ]
i would imagine there was a big shack
why don't they just keep giving me this
thing called wallace's giant bee which
was
two and a half inches oh we can spend
two and a half inches that ain't [ __ ] i
know
what do you think let's let's google it
what do you think i bet that dog was
like [ __ ] 30 feet long
look how big it is though i mean we have
that um
that thing that's right there that's a
tarantula hawk that's on in front of the
skull
see that little glass bottle oh can i
yes yeah that's from uh
maynard you know maynard from tulle
maynard keane he has these
that's him his from his farm that's this
is him
that's his it's him that's he's
haunting this room through that bug
that's from his farm he you know he runs
uh he has vineyards
and he uh he sees these [ __ ] up there
yeah if this if if we think about
history as exponential
then these [ __ ] have to be 11 inches
exactly
[Laughter]
science [ __ ] science
okay let's let's ask this what do you
think the biggest bug ever
is what's the biggest bug ever
in history make sure make sure it's like
the biggest bug in history like millions
of years
i say two feet okay
[Laughter]
all right um i want to say bigger
really yeah i want to think there's like
some [ __ ] sarah pods
that are technically bugs ugh is that
what they're called seropod theropods
some of those crazy uh cephalopods maybe
and then crazy oh yeah those [ __ ]
that are like
like
yeah there was some creepy old bugs back
in the day for sure
yeah i want to say it might be three
feet you could probably
like it's different so i guess it's like
a lobster and crabs are technically
that's what the divers call and they
call them bugs there are bigger ones of
those than this
largest dragonfly i'd show me there's
like 1.8 meters i feel like there's got
to be a crab or
what's the conversion bigger than that
uh three feet
and then 0.8 uh point is this is
compared to a six foot person it's not
that big
it's pretty big all right that's trying
to climb
in your [ __ ] if that was trying to
climb in your [ __ ] you'd be very
unhappy
that's big but yeah but compared to a
person
so then they say that's the largest
instinct ever
distinct insect 275 million years ago oh
not that impressive so i'm impressed
if you change the parameters and what an
insect is then we could yeah but
no not even an insect
that's like a large hot dog that's what
it's like i have largest bug ever in
history and it's just
the largest bug ever
we're lucky they're little man we're
lucky they're little i just found out a
few years ago
that when when um
locusts come and they swarm into like uh
like an area and ruin cornfields and
[ __ ] like that
those are grasshoppers some weird change
happens to grasshoppers and they become
locusts
and it doesn't happen all the time
there's like some possessed
you know we're trying to like write it
down as some sort of technical
hormonal change inside the animal but
maybe that is every now and then they
get possessed by demons
and we're just trying to figure it out
what makes harmless little green
grasshoppers turn it into
brown crop chomping clouds of swarming
locust serotonin no [ __ ]
yup according to a study published this
week in science it took just
two to three hours for timid
grasshoppers in a lab to morph
into a gregarious locusts into
gregarious locusts after they were
injected with serotonin
wow wow so they it changes this chemical
changes what they are and they get
bigger i think
right don't they get bigger they look
bigger well you saw
grasshopper eat a carrot so they get up
there
that was a ridiculous grasshopper like
if you were on your bike
and your face hit that grasshopper like
you'd be [ __ ] you might get knocked
off the bike
right it looks like it's gonna be like a
baseball bro that's a bird
you hit a bird like if you hit a bird
with your face while you're driving your
bike
like you're probably gonna fall down you
probably
you might might be able to take it if
you get that wiggle with a bike
keep your wits about you you get hit in
the face with a bird
i mean planes go down right they do
birds get sucked into the [ __ ] engine
one bird
i think it's more than one bird you need
a few birds
i think you need a lot of beaks but the
stuff i think grinds up quick beaks are
keto yeah the meat grinds up quick
i think it's the beaks the beaks of the
issue
it blows my mind too rolls-royce makes
turbines
yeah for jet engines that's the crazy
[ __ ] they make dope stuff man
that's a weird pretty bad you company
right
everybody know you're not [ __ ] around
i have a rolls-royce derby
on my uh airplane i don't
yeah no this is i was just playing a
character would you drive a rolls royce
would i yeah yeah
you have one beautiful what does it feel
like when you drive around that thing
like a boat it's like you're on a
pontoon
but you're also on a you're on like
there's if you wanted to go to the king
of the the custom car like the king of
the
expensive luxury car it's rolls royce
that's the king
yeah there's something about it you
driving around you got that grill
come on son you got stars in the roof
ladies love it there's on the roof
that's right stars on the roof
you gotta do that in the bronco no
uh that would be no you can't do that to
a 72 bronco
you're not allowed to do that that's
gross
you can't you can't put that blue light
inside the wheel well
ah stop doing that stop doing that
listen man i got blue light in my wheel
well
you can have that if you like
you're a different person a lot of
people should not put blue light in the
wheel well of their classic bronco but
yours is from the
oj days yeah right that's okay you can
do whatever you want to those
i'm happy to see that here because
there's a certain charm about broncos
that i think
a lot of people understand they make you
smile
i see a nice bronco it makes me smile
there's something about it even the new
ones i love
it look at that that's my explorer
that's a 92
ford explorer ladies and gentlemen you
got a 92
ford explorer with those kind of crazy
going doors
yeah the back ones don't work they're
hard to
it's hard to get in but it looks cool i
think
the person who did those winged doors
the best is tesla
that tesla x yeah the going
it goes straight up in the air and then
it comes straight down
i mean those things are sick and
i like christmas mode what's christmas
mode i've seen the dance mode
yeah that's the party what
maybe you just do dance mode during
december and then it's christmas
tiffany experiences back in the days we
were allowed to go to the comedy store
tiffany haddish was in the parking lot
and she had her car on dance mode she
had it playing music and
the car was dancing she was dancing in
front of it and a bunch of us were
dancing too
it was hilarious it's like a car dancing
what were your moves like my dance moves
yeah they were very subtle
very like barely yeah look at that [ __ ]
yeah that's the christmas
that's it also plays trans-siberian
orchestra
this is what happens when you get super
smart dudes and you give them too much
free time
you're like what else you guys want to
do and they're like elon what we want to
do
is we want to make it dance like okay
that's for christmas
super cool we want to make a dance for
christmas halloween
every holiday yeah
that's a different animal too like the
the tesla animal's a different animal
when you're in one of those it doesn't
even feel like a car
it feels like you're on you're on some
next level thing you're in some
oh this is what the future of cars is oh
yeah it's here right now
would you drive a entirely autonomous
car
i think you're going to have to
eventually i don't think so
i think they're going to get so good at
making those things not crash that will
completely
eliminate auto accidents i think then
there's something
there's something that
could have you seen upgrade yes
i did fun movie and then great movie
yeah car gets hacked yes that's right
that's right right i think always and i
can't speak for the next generation but
i think
i will always until i die drive my
motor vehicle i think that
we're old school yeah
you're younger than me but there will be
people younger than you and 10 20 years
from now they'll be
different right dealing with a totally
different reality like there's a lot of
kids today that are just used to uber
right that's what they do they just use
lyft or they use uber and they barely
drive anywhere
avoids drunk driving doesn't cost that
much they just travel around with other
people driving them
right they're used to someone else
driving so if all of a sudden it comes
along that you can get a car
that can drive you around and with 100
certainty not crash into other cars
right like did they all communicate with
each other
right they're going to say hey people we
think about
how many people die from car accidents
every year right now think about what
what
what we would do to bring those people
back all you have to do is not drive
your car and that's how it happens
it doesn't happen because anybody's evil
it doesn't happen it's just like this is
what people do they get
more and more control over their
environment and more and more control
over safety and more and more control
over what you can and can't do because
you don't want to violate
the safety protocols if everybody else
is using the autonomous car and you're
in your crazy bronco
and you smash into someone that's your
fault you [ __ ] up
if you didn't have that bronco post
malone it's just like
it's just like an airplane flight if i'm
gonna die on an airplane
i would rather know that i'm gonna die
rather than
be completely out of control i wonder
what the situation
if you were asleep probably
they never woke you up you took two
two of those uh ambience and just
[ __ ] crashed
i'm just gonna lay here got a couple
[Laughter]
if you knew how to fly a plane yeah
everything would be different
the sure if you knew how to fly an
airplane yeah
the anxiety of flying would be gone i
don't think that's true
because you still you understand that
turbulence
is controllable
and you can figure it out yeah but i
think
when [ __ ] goes wrong it goes really
wrong it's always going to be there
right there's always going to be that
fear but then as a passion
as a passenger yeah it's kind of like
being with a crazy driver
you're like oh he's making me nervous
yeah a little bit
could be but then i mean turbulence is
uncontrollable
but you feel
more comfortable having known if
this crazy driver goes crazy you can
grab the wheel and
know how to drive [ __ ]
imagine that scenario drinking champagne
hanging with your buddies on a plane
thinking everything's groovy
all sudden pilot has a stroke and then
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] posty knows how to fly a
plane
he's gonna save the day what if they
both get sick with some crazy disease
you only stopped in hawaii for one night
but something that the [ __ ]
pilots they're sick with a contagious
disease and they're in the front
so they're zombies dude the pilots are
zombies
yeah we just made a [ __ ] dope ass
movie right now
doesn't it chuck palinduck doesn't he
have a movie
or a book here's a short story where a
person turns into a werewolf on a plane
somebody somebody sent it to me alone
that sounds awesome yeah i think it's a
little girl a little girl becomes a
werewolf on a plane it's called survivor
wait what well he's got two
about a plane sorry it's uh a kid
becomes a werewolf on a plane google
that
that's what i did type that in what is
that he had a collection
of he had a collection of horror stories
didn't he okay that's
called haunted haunted yeah that's chuck
palahniuk right
am i saying his name right i believe so
thank you see
yeah that's it that's it and one of them
is about uh am i remembering this seems
super
obscure it popped up when i was looking
through here let me see if i can find
the thing about uh
this is the same guy who wrote fight
club really interesting guy
had him on the podcast for a very
interesting guy
super smart uh but
what a [ __ ] imagination so
that's a great movie of creepy thoughts
right
pilots pilots get the zombie disease
before taking off and then the pilots
become
zombies on the flight there it is a 13
year old
chihuahua indian girl transformed as if
as if a werewolf aboard the plane and
caused the crash
she relates her theory to missing link
who tells her the girl
in question was his sister okay i think
i just gave away some spoilers
um what's in the box what's in the box
no no no no no no
no what do you do with kevin spacey what
happens with that guy now
i have no idea that's he's the guy he's
kaiser
isn't he wasn't he the guy in that movie
uh uh that was brad pitt i was doing
brad pitt but he's the killer
i was doing brad pitt i know but i was
saying he's saying it to kevin spacey
then he kills kevin spacey right
i'm 25. i hear you bro
that's one of the best answers anybody's
ever given to anything one of the most
self-aware
answers anybody's ever given to anything
how about this first great [ __ ] movie
man seven
jesus christ that was a vivid movie
large torso kevin spacey
okay there it is
it's not the smallest torso i'm not i
mean
you're jealous you're a little bit
jealous you know your torso
seems like he's got a good uh good lung
capacity
take a big deep breath
what's in the box
that's a creepy ass [ __ ] movie man i
love a good creepy movie
me too but true detective was kind of
like
seven for me the first season yes
i like them supernatural i like creepy
movies supernatural or with monsters
because i know they're [ __ ] that way
like ones that are like too close to
humans to actual human beings
i like i like kind of like the slasher
type vibe to where it's like
oh there's a dude in a mask that wants
to [ __ ] everybody up
because i know if it was my house i'd
just pop the [ __ ] and then
burn it um i don't think that works with
jason it works with jason
but he always comes back he made like a
hundred movies well what was the last
movie
the last movie was jamie curtis she's
still [ __ ] with this dude
oh that's a different one yeah it's
michael myerson
my dad used to scare the [ __ ] out of me
and he knew
uh michael meyer scared the [ __ ] out of
me and for halloween
he put the mask on and scared the living
[ __ ] out of me
that's a terrible thing to do to a kid
well that's what i'm so
[ __ ] up to michael michael myers
is halloween and jason is which one had
more movies
only a few
do you remember leprechaun yes yes
i do leprechaun killed jason oh my god
that happened it got to a point where
freddie krueger was fighting jason
and the only [ __ ] that could
kill jason was [ __ ] freddie cruz
oh that's so stupid
oh my god it's so stupid look at him
yeah
man leprechaun yo there is a leprechaun
versus jason
there really is someone might have
edited this cleverly no i remember this
this was an actual movie i don't think
so are you sure
i remember leprechaun in space well why
don't you google whether or not
well i did and i just clicked on the
first that pops up leprechaun versus
jason was a movie
i think people are edited some [ __ ] well
why don't you google it i'd walk yeah
yeah
everybody jesus christ i did and all
that comes up is youtube clips i don't
think it's a real movie um
what about that look a fan played sure i
made for a fan-made trailer
see it's yo people ask for is jason
stronger than freddy
[Laughter]
which jason is the scariest jason
and leprechaun how is someone not make
that movie there's guys
yo can we look at the deal can we look
up leprechaun jason fan fiction
bro before coving there has to be some
fanfic
of leprechaun and jason 100 there has to
be
but before kovet you could probably walk
into any like uh
any of those horror movie making
producer's office
and and pitch that idea and they'd be
like oh [ __ ] why didn't we think of that
leprechaun versus jason in space in
space
in yellowstone and michael michael myers
is the director
how many movies were there with jason it
has to be like 20 right
it's like more okay let's ask this more
jason's or more mission impossibles
more jason really for sure it's a lot of
mission impossibles there's like five
right i don't know i was trying to find
the newest one the other day i was
trying to watch something
crazy and mindless there's a lot of born
identities
12 there's 12 friday the 13th yeah
oh my god that prophecy will be commit
concluded
on the 13th yeah exactly they're waiting
for that
ten years no they're waiting for a
leprechaun that's
this is the trailer for the [ __ ]
movie jamie
this is the trailer you saying that us
looking up everybody laughing
it's jason voorhees and the leprechaun
together at last
why'd you get killed by a leprechaun
he'd be like i can't believe this [ __ ]
like if you're a girl you go home if
you're a groupie and you go home with
the uh
the goblin or the necrogoblin yeah
i can't even say he's a real goblin i
can't even say the word
necro glove goblin goblin's hard to say
it would be a great stephen king book
right there a goblin who is he still
writing
a guy in makeup oh yeah yeah he still
writes look at that leprechaun
terrifying
terrified there's a great stephen king
movie about a vampire that flies around
at night in his own plane
it's great in terms of like let me just
like stress
it's classic it's like it's like eight
very 80s
like it's not great like you see it like
man this is like they made it yesterday
not like uh you know like a
you know like a classic uh francis ford
coppola movie or
stanley kubrick movie not like that but
it's called nightflyer i think it's a
really good book i read the book it's
like a short story i think
and then the movie is this vampire just
flying around [ __ ] people up and then
he
he covers his plane during the day he
just
lays out there and they have to figure
out what the [ __ ] going on and there's
this vampire with his own plane
flying around and [ __ ] people up
that's pretty cool
i watched salem's lot for the first time
it was a made for tv thing salem's live
yeah
it was like [ __ ] nine hours long yeah
yeah yeah
it was like a made for like network
television miniseries
well that was it too it was made the
first was it
was a television thing right i think so
that was the one with uh the guy from
rocky horror picture show right
um isn't it alice cooper no the
who is tim curry tim curry is the first
it he was the first it in the tv version
of it
which was like believe it or not scary
at the time
no that movie sucks i hate it it scares
the [ __ ] out of me still
but they're nothing compared to the new
ones the new it's that's the new yeah
that's i think this guy's i think this
guy's scarier than the new guy
that's pretty scary we all float down
here
cowboy look at that face man jesus
christ
so that's the 1990 pennywise
yeah there's something about that that
might actually be creepier
yeah it's just like [ __ ]
lifeless well there's something about it
it's a real
it's the thing about that is like if you
looked into a sewer
and you saw a man like that's a real
thing that's not like cgi
no that's like yeah there's no effects
yeah the thing about the new one is it
scares the [ __ ] anybody opens its mouth
then clamps down bites a kid
arm off right you're like um that's not
it's not really happening
yeah do you know michael myers mess was
will shatner
what really was it will shatner mouse
yeah
no [ __ ] it was ah yeah
there's a lot of information on it
but michael myers mass was uh like a
will shatner oh my god
it was supposed to be captain kirk
apparently but oh my god
they just took the eyebrows off it's
[ __ ] terrifying
it oh my god it is that is who he is
how weird isn't that weird [ __ ] real
weird but that's how it [ __ ] goes
it's like the uncanny valley there's
something about someone wearing a mask
too like that kind of mask
like you can't you don't see any
humanity yeah it's just
i'm gonna [ __ ] destroy it yes
from the darkness that's what we're all
scared of right we're all scared of some
super powerful demonic [ __ ] that's
outside of our control
jason's coming demons are coming what if
demons existed but really rarely
just like ufos like these people that
have taken selfies
at the grand canyon and they're like
posed and like look and then also
ah what if this little demon is just
waiting for
in the grand canyon yeah everywhere just
whatever just waiting for you to do
something there's just a couple
there's like there's like 15. there it
is night flyer
yeah look at that that's the vampire
that's that guy's the reporter
he's gonna expose the vampire
i see when i say it's really good i
don't mean it's really good
i mean it's really good because it's
kind of schlocky and crazy
and you're watching this [ __ ]
he's not fighting back very well no he
can't i like the vampire's so much power
he has to do what the vampire says
the book is cooler for sure
the book is really cool there's another
book that's really good that stephen
king did about aliens called the tommy
knockers
that's a great book that's about um a
ufo that was like
buried in the in the ground near a town
and its energy started [ __ ] everybody
up
like it was it was messing with people
investing because there was this
this thing that was right and that that
was a great book that they made a movie
out of it but the movie didn't really
kind of
capture what the book was about it's too
hard
it makes sense radiation
i guess yeah radiation i'm not a doctor
outer space
craft [ __ ] how do you react how do
you react to that who knows man
who knows you seen bright burn bright
burn
what's that so it's like it's like
superman if he was bad superman if he
was bad
if he was evil okay i i thought it was
great
it's a movie yeah it's a movie oh when
did this come out
two years ago really yep god you should
watch you should watch
whatever loop you should watch this
[ __ ] pretty good
yeah dude that sounds incredible it's
literally like
parallel superman it but if he was like
bullied and treated like [ __ ] and he was
angry whoa just imagine that
oh my god imagine that if you had that
power but you were
angry instead of wanting to help people
right like who says super
heroes want to help people oh my god
yeah imagine if you're like super
[ __ ] annoying but you're also
super powerful
you're from another planet but you smell
weird and the girls here don't like you
yeah [ __ ] you're [ __ ] 12 and you're
like
god damn it and you just get angry and
you become and you [ __ ] you let him
know
squish your mom listen [ __ ] i'm more
powerful than all you [ __ ]
ants that's i always think about that
too if there was a real
superhero would he lay low or would he
be like
i am god he would i am
beating girls off his dick 24 hours a
day and you wouldn't
have a chance to save the world because
it would be just lined up
there's a show called the boys right
they don't want that dna
oh yeah it's a like a superhero show
yeah but it's like
superheroes are like celebrities but it
would be on such a
more grand scale bro but if you were the
only one too
you would be like
the the king of the planet well that's
that was always my problem with the
watchmen not my problem but
like uh an interesting part of the
watchmen story
was dr manhattan right who was basically
a god right
he could do anything right there was it
seemed to be no limit to his powers i
mean he lived in
space and his wiener was huge huge giant
blue hog and that was being interrupted
you could show them in a movie right
remember
a lot more hogs in movies nowadays
well now they're desperate it's like all
they have is [ __ ] hard
to show the hog it was for a while you
could be cavalier about
hiding your hogs you didn't have to go
to
show in the hog in order to get ratings
but now goddammit with netflix
they can do anything we got to show some
hogs we got hogs on netflix but in that
movie it was like
remember when they had dr manhattan like
you got out of the shower or something
like that and you're like jesus
like you see his big old dick and you
you had to
so if you went to just to see a
superhero movie and you're out where
your girl you're having some popcorn
drinking some diet coke enjoying this
movie
all of a sudden you see a big old blue
dick that you did not expect
but what about when he goes giant blue
hog
full size like huge like in new york
walking around
yeah yeah with this giant blue deck just
swinging
what does god's dick look like like that
it's perfect not too big not too small
it's like the perfect tits aren't like
triple e fake boobs
right there's a there's a perfect time
perfect dick's ridiculous
like what is the number like a dude with
a giant carpet roll dick that's no good
like that's now you've got a handicap
there's a there's a comfortable
time like whatever the size you got to
stop right there and don't be greedy
i'm happy here normal good for you
normal is a good place to be man
normal's a good time i don't want the
doctor manhattan dick yeah you don't
want any of that [ __ ]
but that dude was a that dude is a real
god yes what's crazy is that could be
people and that could be people in 100
years with gene editing
and technology crispr crispr and then
the ability to
incorporate technology inside of human
beings
when they figure out how to put
processors inside of human beings and
make you smarter
to figure out a way to connect your
brain connect it
through the air with the internet you're
always connected that's the next move
it's going to happen that that's the
next move is your wallets in your body
there was a video and i don't know if it
was fake
jamie there was a video where there was
a corporation that was
they convinced their employees to get a
microchip in their arm is that fake
that was real no [ __ ]
and they used it to like buy things at
lunch and they could use it to open
doors
dude they stuck this thing in their
[ __ ] arm
so they have like this rfid chip in
their arms like
like if you want to work there you have
to get it in your arm
it sounds like the bellco experiment
just imagine that man you want to work
at ups
great we need to stick a [ __ ]
electronic
but that's what's inside your body i
mean 97
of money is digital
right like how much of it is actual gold
three percent look at that thing
they planted that in that dude's [ __ ]
hand no now what if he does jujitsu
then what huh that thing's gonna break
you're gonna have to cut it out it's
gonna get infected
god damn it no no [ __ ] bro
there's a [ __ ] company and these
people are lining up to get this [ __ ]
injected into their body look at that
guy he's like
i should have stayed in college that's
what he's thinking right now he's
thinking i should own this company
these guys are all [ __ ] i can't
believe everyone's willing to get this
thing
inserted in their [ __ ] body i can't
believe i couldn't
ever it's crazy i couldn't ever what is
the
the the company's name well excuse me
three square market
i think i read about it once but like
it's uh they might have been doing like
proof of concept to show this could work
for other companies which
is that what they do do they do these
things so like you could
uh almost like i think like those amazon
go stores where you can just walk in
grab what you want
and leave this that your chip knows how
much money you have and it just scans
the scanner
or whatever on the way out that's so
what if you don't
what if you don't have money no that
follows what if you don't have money
one of those robots well what if you
build up that debt
it's like 10 grand and chip that and
then they gotta [ __ ] take your
[ __ ] hand
i robot knocks on your door bang bang
bang man
we are here to collect money from you
post malone it's the suede denim secret
police
[ __ ] westworld you watched that show
yeah think about the first season
artificial people you're allowed to
shoot
artificial pee-pee people oh okay robot
people you're allowed to shoot
[Laughter]
that would be a great stephen king book
right a goblin that tricks people into
thinking it's a man in a mask
how about a goblin with a microchip that
runs out of money
and then he has to go on the run from
his [ __ ]
his debt collector yeah right that's a
cool movie
yeah that's a cool you get a little bit
of lord of the rings you get a little
bit of high rope you get all that [ __ ]
he has to tell people like i keep my
phone off most of the time because the
debt collectors just blow my phone up
i only turned on it a couple minutes a
day just
maybe maybe you think
the chip just goes crazy
and it gives you the advantages of
implants over
cards is their permanence they are
unlikely to be lost
and are non-transferable businesses do
not need to worry about
theft or access details to the same
degree
because to do so would involve
mutilation and be much more obvious what
what the [ __ ] is that they say
mutilation
in the army someone that's incredible
stealing your chip
so they could cut it off your body from
a business perspective it also allows a
more precise tracking of employees
due to the in-body nature of an implant
over a car
oh my god listen to this but this
statement is so bizarre
mutilation in the article businesses do
not need to worry about theft or
of access details to the same degree
because to do so would involve
mutilation and be much more obvious
imagine you don't have to worry about
someone cutting that chip out of your
[ __ ] hip and using it to open all the
building
and stealing all the information because
that would be obvious no it'd be really
obvious everyone would see it coming
and it would involve mutilation
i love mutilation in the paragraph
that's my favorite
you're sitting around at your house
thinking i can't believe i let these
[ __ ] inject this thing in my
hip
just feeling it every morning you touch
this thing that's what i
well that's what i was getting at if
you're overdue
on your balance it would just irritate
you
there would be something that would
irritate you to the point of insanity
wake up and get another job to pay me
what who are you you're [ __ ]
neurological
and like who said that yeah the chip
it's your chip
it's chip yeah it's the overlord
we are communicating to you from your
chip you don't want us to
involve mutilation in this [ __ ]
because that would be obvious
it would be too obvious it would be too
obvious
those like the most non-soothing
yeah if they were trying to sell that
[ __ ] it's not working
that is the least soothing way to say no
one's gonna steal the chip
cause they didn't have to cut it out of
you
it would involve mutilation holy [ __ ]
imagine no one mutilates don't worry
it's
totally safe no one's ever mutilated
it's not like
they don't even have a really good
reason for you to do it of course i used
to like to use copy machines
open doors use the copy machine
how about i just press [ __ ] copy
how about i press start boss
you can't put a [ __ ] chip in me [ __ ]
what if that chip rots
what happens if you play rugby and the
chip breaks inside your arm
says you can put it take it out just as
easy as a splinter that's a lie
but then it says mutilation the chip is
about this [ __ ] big that's the
biggest splinter i've seen
that's hilarious oh my god they would
just have to
bowie knife it out of you ugh that's got
to be a
[ __ ] it probably is a dark mirror
episode right
is there one of those where someone gets
a chip i think every episode of black
mirror they have a chip
yeah they've figured it out black
mirrors figured out everything that's
gonna happen everything is gonna go
wrong
you had the cloning thing earlier with
that cloning episode that dude had
remember where they had the
the space station team like oh yes
yes yes yes yes
that was the one where the guy was a
tyrant right yeah
[ __ ] that was a creepy one that was a
creepy one
i like the video game one where he goes
stays at that old mansion
and he just goes [ __ ] nuts
that's a good one how long before
they're gonna make an artificial post
malone looks just like you
sits right next to you freaks out is he
doing my shows
no he's got no talent
i think there's gonna be it's gonna be a
long road
before they figure out a way to make an
artificial thing that's creative
i think that might be the only thing we
have well they try to make computers
make music all the time
it sucks sucks there's something that we
do
we like we were talking about earlier it
r when you're doing something
we i mean humans that makes other people
happy
that thing is hard to define
it's hard to figure out with numbers
like you listen to eye of the tiger and
you want to start running
like what is that let a computer [ __ ]
make that camera
if you were a kid when i was when rocky
iii came out and that [ __ ] song comes
out holy
[ __ ] yeah
come on man what are my chances of the
artificial posty sitting here
while i out take a piss i knew i knew it
was coming go go take a piss bro
we have plenty of time we'll be right
back ladies and gentlemen
and this is supernova by necro goblin
khan
we'll be right back yeah disc problems
are no joke man
that's a if you have like bulging desks
or herniated discs
you got to take care of those what you
definitely can't do is [ __ ] them up
worse
sure like if you have a chance do
something take they're real close to
being able to fix that too
they're already replacing them they're
replacing them with these titanium discs
that move around
they're not perfect but it's better than
you know having
degenerative disc disease and having
massive pain all the time and that's
something that's not something that i'm
mad at
is what i meant a disc
i'm mad at chips in your hands that you
have to mutilate to get out
yeah that's scary people are totally a
piece a piece of metal
instead of a bone isn't harmful
no because there's no technology in that
it's just a filler right right it's just
something to replace something that's
broken right like if your hand gets
bitten off by a shark
and they say listen you have two options
right you can have no hand
or will make you a hand that looks
exactly like your old hand
luke skywalker style right and you put
that on you can feel with it and
everything but it just won't be a real
hand
no i mean that's totally fine too if if
it's controlled by
your brain and you wake up in the middle
and it's choking you and see
that's that's that's the whole that's
the whole argument
that could happen that could happen
come on man some terminator [ __ ] how
strong would your goddamn hand be if it
was made out of metal
and wires and [ __ ] you think
do you think you couldn't fight
a robot no they would fall up if you had
a metal hand you couldn't fight
no they wouldn't let you no no chance
you can't have a metal thing that would
be that would be like the new
one is hard as [ __ ] metal metal-handed
people are people too
and they would want to enter into mma
and [ __ ] people up with their iron arms
oh my god that that's that dude's oh
[ __ ] bobby gilder but he's got something
i just was looking at this crazy hook
thing oh so he makes a bunch of
different that's cool
it doesn't say i don't think so he he
has different prosthetics that he does
different things with
yeah no context for that i met him he's
got a carbon fiber articulating hand and
a carbon fiber leg he got attacked by a
shark
is is the hand controllable yeah he can
move it like this
with his nerves i don't know how it's
hooked up do you know how it's hooked up
nope i don't know if it's muscle and i
was like
well that was normal maybe he contracts
it with his muscles man
that's the whole thing that's like
that's
okay yeah i know we've done if somebody
gets
it's like the self-driving car right
right if there's a way for somebody to
control that
and it's not just your nerves or
whatever controlling
right instead of
it's hooked up to the cloud or something
somewhere like the [ __ ] chip
you know what i mean i do know what you
mean look i've never played an acoustic
guitar
right but i would imagine it's probably
a
pretty magical experience to play in
like a really
good guitar it's very visceral and
satisfying
that that analog visceral
satisfying feeling of doing something
that there's that exists in the car
world too if you look if you're driving
like a 1969
porsche 911 those air cooled cars they
weigh like 2 000 pounds
and it's a it's got this crazy weird
mechanical sound to it bro
that there's a thing there's a
connection you have to that that you're
not going to get once you start adding
technology
all that shit's gone that weird thing
that that very
analog thing that you get from like
it exists with a lot of it it exists
with looking at a painting
it exists with listening to someone
saying it exists
with with jokes with there's a thing man
when you can just [ __ ] nail like a
thing that makes you
feel those cars make you feel better
that's the difference
like an old car will make you feel
better
right that's a new car is not going to
do that a new car is going to be cool as
[ __ ] and awesome
right but it's not going to make you
feel better like there's something about
yeah yeah you feel better you're on a
drug
it's a very mild amazing drug
you're not gonna get that off a
spaceship that's autonomous you know
it's autonomously driving
yeah and that's the whole that's the
whole deal
it's like you know
there is technology that's helpful
technology does not go with
the human body yeah it's this is like
organic right you know what i mean yes
and like the chip
it's it's gonna go wrong sometimes for
sure it has to
it's not it's gonna be perfect all the
people with the chip are 100 happy
yeah none of them got infections no
mutilation she was happy nobody
there was no mutilation it was never so
obvious that's what i'm saying like if
you have to have
a piece or a disc in your spine removed
with a metal plate instead of
a metal plate with a microchip in it
that's the total difference you know
what i mean
i do know what you mean but what if that
microchip made you feel better
what if they put that microchip in you
and all of a sudden
this is how i want you to look at it
what it is
is essentially new software management
of your body
your mind will stay the same post malone
right but your body
will now be in control of this perfect
system
that's gonna figure out what it needs
and what it doesn't need
work it all out you just live your life
you don't have to worry about your body
anymore
i've already seen too many movies about
don't worry about your mind not into it
it's fine everything's gonna be
wonderful
it's okay it is cool to be cyborg
if you're living a shitty life you're
like i [ __ ] hate delivering for
postmates
i hate [ __ ] where i sleep i hate i
hate what i do
i'm tired i don't want to do it anymore
then all sudden this this little thing
comes along
right give control of your body to the
state
you still be the same inside your mind
but our microchip will control
all of your biology to the point where
you no longer need to go to the doctor
you don't need health insurance because
you're never going to get sick
right one but one by one people give in
interesting we get infected interesting
affected by technology interesting
don't you think it's possible most
definitely but is it better
here's the thing is it better if your
grandmother dies of cancer
or is it better if you have some
technology that keeps you from ever
getting any disease ever
but it's embedded inside your body and
it's controlled
by a team of scientists but it comes
to i was watching something
that this robot can walk and swim so it
gets in your cells makes its way through
to your brain and [ __ ] explodes
jihad this is the craziest thing ever
that what that what they're willing to
do today
with um with technology and
you know like what they're experimenting
on what we're seeing in these videos is
just a
tiny amount of what's possible for them
in the future
i mean they could man we could have
insane technology of changing human
bodies inside our lifetime
you're in shape right i try my best
me not so much do you ever want to be no
well there you go then yeah i mean i'm
happy here as long as you're happy
but like we were talking about earlier
it comes to
i guess generation wise yes because
if you have to pantomime a cell phone
how do you do it you got to do like this
like this yeah
flip phone but i saw a video
of are they doing this now they're doing
this oh okay that makes sense
because of the iphone yeah but we do it
like this
yeah so
there there maybe later comes a time
because like i said i will never drive a
fully autonomous car
[Music]
but i hear you i'm sure there's someone
years down the line that will be like oh
[ __ ] yeah are you kidding me
i think they're going to do it because
it's safer and i think that's why it's
going to be really hard to get people
to uh sign off on the idea of letting
people drive their own cars
it's a thing that we got really used to
that we only got used to for a little
while
i mean there was no cars in 1700
and in the 2020s everyone's got a
[ __ ] car they're everywhere
so in that time period we went from all
of human history
no cars to the invention of a car
whatever the [ __ ] that was we figured
that out once
in the 1800s or something the 1800s they
figured out that was their first car
that's not that long and then we just
decided well you have to have a car
basic human right you don't really have
to have a car
but cars are awesome like i know you do
need this other car
how are you going to get to your job
public transportation if it's better
that's what but that's a car well not
necessarily
it could be like a tube where people fly
through it it's all magnets on the other
end to keep it from crashing into each
other
they could figure out some weird [ __ ]
that has nothing to do with cars
it's too late it's not totally too late
i think if they could figure out a way
to convince people that there will be no
more auto accidents
that would be a good way to get people
on board right if they said no more auto
accidents ever
people would probably be like oh well
how can you argue against that you
selfish [ __ ]
you want to shift through your own gears
and kill my nana
and that's that's what people are going
to do they're going to give in to it
because they don't want to be selfish
i mean this is like the slow slide into
accepting that we're a part of
technology
right the slow slide is us hanging on to
our biology as much as possible
i think that's a good thing i think
biology is awesome
but i see the writing on the wall i see
where it's going yeah i mean it's going
away yeah
we're sliding into this uh new existence
but we we're really insistent on keeping
our old ways it's really weird
i know in terms of like uh i like to
hear the rumble of an engine i'm one of
those people i
have a rumble of an engine right but
then
it i mean i i don't want to backtrack
too much but i have been but
at the end of the day i would rather
be responsible for my decisions i
suppose yes
well you're an artist you know you're
just being an artist is a different kind
of person it's a person who's chosen a
path of doing whatever the [ __ ] they
want to do
like expressing themselves
professionally of course you don't want
someone driving you
it feels good to drive yeah there's
experiences that you get
in life you want to you want to feel
them all you know and some of them are
dangerous
some of them come with consequences if
you make a mistake that's how you get
better
if you take away all consequences
my concern is that we're going to just
like keep protecting ourselves
more and more and more and more and more
and more and more and more to it to the
point where we're just
incapable of withstanding any adversity
that's what i'm worried about with
people
well and that's what i say i this is
this is why i would rather
drive my own car is because like
you never fully
you never you wake up and you never know
what's happening
right right you never know what's gonna
happen during the day
there's something good about that yeah
no it's incredible
but we're all
people and
i would rather have that be biological
then a computer controlled
and that's and that's where i'm coming
from i suppose
i i'm with you i'm with you i see both
sides of it i really do
right i'm not on a particular side of it
right
because i think um i think what all of
us are doing is like witnessing these
changes happening in real time
and trying to hold on to whatever ground
we have that we think is important and
sacred
you know i think that's one of the
things we're doing where
you know people that ride motorcycles
they want to ride harleys and loud
engines and
it's romantic it's exciting all those
things i think are cool
but i see the writing on the wall like
if a hundred years from now
it's it's all going to be autonomous
yeah there's going to be very few
licenses that we give away to people to
let them drive their own cars
right it's probably it's probably all
going to be controlled by some central
system that keeps you at a certain pace
you know you gotta it's it's gonna be
annoying
it's gonna be annoying it's gonna be
just drive to work no more fun anymore
before it's like if you worked at a job
and you had a 68 camaro
right and you drove your 68 camaro to
work while you're driving down the
street listening to white snake
here i go again on my own and you're
driving this [ __ ] thing and you're
shifting your own gears right that guy's
having a good ass
time and someone can come along take
that away and say no
no you have to get in the autonomous
tube now because safety
safety is important so this poor [ __ ]
dude who
looked forward to his drive to work he
had a 20-minute drive to work but during
that 20 minutes
he listened to all the music he wanted
to listen to
he listened to whatever the [ __ ] he
wanted right and then he pulled into
that and
pulled into that [ __ ] parking spot
shut his car off right now he's got to
go to work but he knows
that in eight hours he'll be free and
fire that car up again
right shift his own look forward to it
drive home listen to the best tunes call
your friends
right you're
what about an attack an attack
what kind of attack like
like you think about it you think about
no you think about you pull out your
debit card right
and all of a sudden no one's debit card
works
oh yeah right what's gonna stop that
from happening
what do you do with no money because
there's only three percent that's real
cash
that's real like palpable
so if everybody wanted all the paper for
all the money they have in the bank we
would never be able to do it
if everybody's debit card stopped
working
it would [ __ ] much cash is there out
there right i have no idea
like how much cash is there out there
now in comparison to like the 80s when
there was only cash
it's probably the same amount but most
people use credit cards now right like
way more yeah but think about if
if we had an enemy that wanted to yeah
say or even or even
our own government that's just like
all technology monetary wise is
cut off yep they just killed the system
they just stopped it all
no more banks no more banking no more
atms
what are you gonna do you don't have any
money you know nobody has any money you
can't buy food you can't buy anything so
you have to steal and then
all your money is everything how much
u.s currency is in circulation as of
july 8 2020 1.3 trillion
look how much how much
is out there how much money how do we
differentiate what is
like digital money right and what is
actual
money good point there's 1.3 trillion
accounted for
but how much of it is an actual paper
cash right yeah yeah
and what does paper cash even worth
depends on
where you're at right some people don't
even want it
some restaurants like no we don't we
don't take cash yeah it's like whoa
you do the yeah it's the thing they flip
it around
it says uh according to the cia the
total amount
of broad money
is 80 trillion dollars whoa currently
and cash was one point two
so 1.9 trillion is actual cash and all
the rest of it is just [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] ethereal yeah
it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] nowhere it
doesn't exist there's not a vault you
can get in like imagination
imagine imagine where
we we're at war with the country
and then they have the best oh my god
hackers yeah or whatever this is all
hypothetical
right but you're you go to swipe your
card
and it doesn't work and then everybody
in america goes to swipe their card and
it doesn't
doesn't work and then you find out the
goblin lead singer of that [ __ ]
goblin is right there
[Laughter]
it's a real goblin and he's eating
people the same way that centipede eats
mice
gets rid of the back of their head
that's a terrible video skull
that's a terrible video i know it's
horrible pretty brutal it is so brutal
and that's what's normal
that's normal out there just we've we
figured out a way to wall it off
that's what it is all day long it's
things eating things it's [ __ ]
chaos yeah things eat things
the ocean is one giant murder soup
that's all it is just monster murder
soup a bunch of [ __ ] things
killing each other how do you feel about
whales i love them they're huge
i've been around them i've never seen
one in my whole life
you should go to hawaii i think it's
around
i want to say it's around november-ish
find out when the whales
go near i've seen them near the big
island on a uh one of them
cruises they take you out i've seen him
a couple times accidentally while
fishing
from maui but i've seen him on the big
island where you go out on a boat ride
humpback whale season in the hawaiian
islands yeah between november and early
may
but some months are better than others
so it's cool man so you're in this boat
and then as you're out there you just
see one break the surface and then they
they
you know lean towards that area they go
to and sometimes you see them
swim under the boat it's incredible
they're so big man
so they don't even seem real biggest
creatures on the planet
oh yeah yeah currently yeah they're the
biggest creatures blue whales are right
aren't they the biggest
i saw something sperm whales maybe blue
whale biggest thing ever
ever i don't know wow yeah
they're so big dude i mean you see
that's different [ __ ] dinosaur
how long have they been around like they
didn't get killed by the yucatan blast
right
aren't they something that's millions of
years old maybe not that many million
maybe that's what it is like we think
about um dolphins and how [ __ ]
intelligent they are how long have they
been around
here we go 173 tons
oh my god oh my [ __ ] god 29.9 meters
which is 100 feet long
it's basically 100 feet long and weighed
173 tons known to have ever
existed oh my god it weighs an adult
weighs 330
000 pounds and they live 90 [ __ ]
years
they live 90 years and they're smart
that's what's weird we don't you know
they take care of the young
they're smart there's some weird mammal
but then there's orcas which are they're
cut like
orcas are the cousins to dolphins that's
the ones we love right we love killer
whales
but they murder dolphins they murder
whales they murder
they're the murderers of the ocean
they're the killer whales
yeah but they call them killer whales
they're not a they're not a whale
they're a dolphin they call themselves
are dolphins yeah they call them killer
whales because they kill whales
so do they rude sex for fun
i don't know if there's that's a good
question because dolphins do because
dolphins do
that's a really good question let's find
out yeah
do orcas have or creational sex
casual or sexual orcas have casual sex
texts for fun you probably get a better
article
you get someone who's got a sense of
humor
do google do orc as [ __ ] for fun you'll
get the best article
got
[Laughter]
i wonder how much they know about them
you know i don't think they know about
them the same way they know about
dolphins is there is there
because that there's not a lot of them
there's not as many as they used to be
that's for sure there's a real worry
about the ones that are in the pacific
northwest
um there's a pod around the seattle area
i think
that for whatever reason doesn't want to
eat anything other than
chinook salmon i think it's chinook
salmon and they're running out of salmon
there's not as many salmon anymore so
these things are starving
and so they're trying to reintroduce
like the idea of getting them to eat
like
seals or sea lions things like that
because other killer whales eat them all
the time
so you have this native pod of killer
whales that's
really struggling and then you have
these pods that are travelers
they travel into the neighborhood they
just [ __ ] everything up they eat all the
seals
they eat whatever they want they eat
mammals they eat fish they eat whatever
they want and then they take off
so they're only there for a little while
but there's one pot for whatever reason
just one salmon
how many is in the pot not that many
they're having a hard time uh keeping
them active
they're even thinking about releasing
extra salmon into the water they've had
a bunch of like
weird ideas of how to uh how to save
them how many
jamie's googling it's scott it says
there's a lot of animals that have sex
not just for reproduction yeah for sure
chimps do but it says they all
work it's also masturbate which i found
in this article
other animals do too how i don't know
just as they re they do stuff
when reproduction isn't they're only on
a rock this is [ __ ] a crab they call it
masturbation it's crab rape
jesus christ oh my god imagine a killer
whale's horny just rubbing up against
you and you're like just
finish please a killer whale just go
ahead
stop getting high with puffer fish right
dolphins do don't they like
pass them around and like yeah dolphins
do what
the stories of killer whales rescuing
people and they fall off boats which is
really crazy
like they've had people they've actually
said killer whales have actually helped
them
it's weird because they kill people in
captivity but only because they're
probably because they're tortured you
know they're living in a [ __ ]
swimming pool
and giant majestic yeah ocean animal
trapped in a prison for no reason
didn't do anything wrong eventually they
just start killing their trainers just
get pissed off
man man holy [ __ ]
you guys are putting me on
do you say they they they get high they
use tough
toxic fish [ __ ] crazy
they take a little toot and they pass it
around
the dolphins expert deliberate handling
of the terrorized
puffer fish implies that this is not
their first time
at the hallucinogenic rodeo like a
volcano what if a human
smokes it's a volcano bag it is what if
a human smoked pufferfish oh you'd
probably be dead in a second
what's it like i don't know but we don't
have a face like that i would imagine a
lot of [ __ ] a dolphin could do that you
can't
swear it's got more poisonous
wow 1200 times wow
more poisonous and cyanide enough toxin
in one puffer fish to kill 30 adult
humans
and there's no known entities
jesus christ meanwhile only resulting in
mutilation
dolphins like i'm just here to get high
i got this
you [ __ ] don't know what you're doing
how does that work i don't know
i never knew that you know what's weird
is that people want to eat them
like uh they're like a prized sushi
meat because it's like it's it's
exciting
you're eating something that the chef
[ __ ] this up your dolphins are puffer
fish
puffer fish i don't like dolphins
there's no dolphin sushi is there i
don't know
there has to be something i don't like i
like warm warm fish
warm fish like cooked yeah baked yeah
yeah i hear you you're not a sushi guy
yeah fugu that's it right there
no [ __ ] yeah so that is a
it's it's a delicacy for whatever reason
people like the idea of eating something
that might [ __ ] kill him
and it has to be expert top 10 most
dangerous
foods served in paper-thin slices by
expert chefs the fugu combines luxury
with high-stakes gamble
the intestines ovaries and liver of fugu
or blowfish contains a poison called
texts
sorry tetrodotoxin okay tetradotoxin
which is 1200 times deadlier than
cyanide
this toxin is so potent that a lethal
doth dose is smaller than the head of a
pin a lethal dose smaller than the head
of a pin
and a single fish is enough poison to
kill 30 people because of the high risk
chefs must undergo two to three years of
training
to obtain a fugu preparing license
and such expertise raises the price of
fugu dishes up to 200
what that's kind of cheap it's really
cheap i think
you might die yeah they consume 10 000
tons of fugu fish every year
oh my god they're so ballsy that's a
warrior culture right there
[ __ ] fugu fish
can't should we try it no i'll try it
bro i don't want to be there when you
die i clicked one i wanted to see what
other foods were first the first food
they listed
hot dogs hot dogs are more dangerous
than fugu fish
i said people choke on them oh please oh
my gosh
90 percent of food related asphyxiations
in those younger than ten are caused
from hot dogs okay well i understand if
it's illegal
i understand little kids and their
parents don't know how to do it i'm like
there's a certain age where you're on
your own if you choke to death on a hot
dog
there's a certain age like hey man
do you know how to give yourself a
heimlich because i don't you gotta throw
yourself on the edge of your chair oh
jesus
i don't know if it will work but that's
what you gotta do do what is it
i find a chair and like get this throw
your body off
chuck the food out of your mouth you
don't just like
hmm maybe yeah just kind of like you
could
maybe like in an in an upwards motion
you get behind someone and you force it
right you force the air out
so what the [ __ ] do you do do you have
to get them bending forward you do right
so that the food when it pops out
doesn't fall right back in their
their hole right actually it says
self-harm like it should be a fist
yeah punch yourself right up in an
upward motion
i'll show you wow what it says to do
both
the best yeah the chair is good okay so
this guy
slammed his hand oh it's like like a
gable grip like you're trying to take
someone down
slam it into your okay right underneath
so right where your solar plexus is
be careful but what kind of chair
there's so many different kinds of
chairs well hey if you're choking you've
got to find the closest one i think i
heard that they break
they people break ribs doing this all
the time makes sense
and then cpr people break ribs doing
that too makes sense
you're pushing on the ribs trying to get
someone to breathe
[Music]
trying to get that food out of their
stomach that [ __ ] hot dog what if the
chair is like a throne like a cool like
vampire throne and it's like sharp on
the top
then you're gonna impale yourself yeah
don't do that then you
that's when you do this don't do the
heimlich when you're near a vampire
throne
it's [ __ ] life lessons here
yeah you ever see that gary oldman
dracula movie
dude that's that's a classic with winona
ryder
and keanu reeves you ever see that
before he got too far i got a picture of
henry heimlich the guy who invented it
popped up
he came up with that 1974 is when i was
promoted so like what the [ __ ] do people
do before that
died they only had been doing it for
like 50 years stabbed themselves with a
[ __ ] vampire
throat that's crazy
wow i'm sure there was something but
like wow the self heimlich manure
maneuver excuse me a poem by fred payton
so there it is heimlich maneuver to
dissolve
heimlich recommended standing behind the
person
wrapping arms around what is that nine
what is that
around nine clasping hands what does
that mean
that's the answer oh and oh and clasping
hands
onto i never know what that sign is
called i know what it is i know it's and
i know it's ampersand once you said it
spell it but if you but if you said to
me
what is that thing called before you
just said that i'd be like i don't know
what the [ __ ] that thing's called
yeah i don't know how you would do it
yourself you would lean forward i guess
and just slam it in
and how do you figure that out you don't
you just like choke yourself with like
just eat steak
and then purposely all the time yeah and
then like well [ __ ] it's gotta work
i think someone probably did it one time
and then the other went
ah the other people went that's what we
do write that down but
heimlich i didn't you said 1972
uh 74. 74. jesus christ
i figured that would have been around
for years
yeah right hundreds of years
[Music]
people just thought demons were taking
you when you're choking on food
and put them in the [ __ ] windshield
billy
the witch jail demons
possessed possessed grasshoppers my
little billy was a good boy
and the demons came and they took him i
was eating hot dogs
seventeen percent he was fine
hot dogs is the most dangerous food
that's crazy more than fugu
that's how much better japanese people
are being humans than americans
we die from hot dogs they don't even die
from this [ __ ] super
toxic thing where one drop the head of a
pen
could kill a whole human being they
don't even dry that doesn't measure out
to me though by the way
enough there's enough poison right
in a puffer fish to kill 30 humans right
but
one pin drop is a lethal dose
yeah they have a very small amount of
poison i guess the policy before this
was slapping somebody on the back
until like 1970 when this guy was like
researching this i found out that it
actually
pushed the food further back down so the
red cross had to have like a
do not allow anyone to slap you on your
back if you're choking and try to
dislodge food
oh my god and then like he said he read
an article
dr heimlich about people dying it was
the sixth most like leading cause of
death
so he's like what a wizard he is
it makes sense with hot dogs though
because you get to bite off those chunks
you know like it's so easy to bite off
and if you're a glutton
or if you just make a mistake and you
just bite off too big of breath
and you think you're all right and
you're like
what's the [ __ ] solution there though
i'm a maneuver vampire throne obviously
bro when you look at how many people
have died from choking ever
it was a lot that's why he was looking
it up it was like in one year six
thousand people died and said you never
hear about it unless it was someone
famous
it's like uh kennedy's sister-in-law or
someone died of choking on me
oh really wow oh
i think i've only been in one dire
choking situation what happened
i was at dinner with my family
at our house and i took a bite
of steak and
it just clogged me up [ __ ] my uncle gave
me the heimlich maneuver
shout out to uh what's his name heimlich
henry heimlich
shout out to henry heimlich yeah
have you ever been in a dire choking
situation
no not really i've definitely been
choking at points like i've had
something like
but i either threw it up or something
never where i was thought this was it
i'm gonna die
i had it's terrifying i could only
imagine have you been you've been there
scary [ __ ] it's freak out just imagine
enjoying a delicious
piece of steak and then you're like
it took a turn yeah and now i'm dying
and you could dive people around you
don't know what the [ __ ] to do you could
die
henry heimlich saved us all yeah you
can't be timid with that heimlich
maneuver either
you gotta really get after yeah you
gotta get after it because
you might not have that much time how
many of those you get
heimlicks how many times can you force
it you know i mean
you could break someone's [ __ ] ribs
too you have to think about that yeah if
you're doing like to an old lady and
she's choking on something
you might kill her doing that yeah oh
imagine you're nana she spits out the
meat but you killed her by giving her
the heimlich
[ __ ] that's an insane situation
[ __ ] that has to happen
has to have happened yeah how long can a
human hold their breath
minutes those free divers they can do
like seven minutes i think
that's a lie no no no they can do it
seven minutes yeah people have done more
than that but they've done it with like
weird
oxygen assist things chris angel not
chris angel but david blaine he did some
crazy
number of minutes but he did something
to himself
first right it wasn't just what do you
know what he did jamie i
was trying to when we were doing the
podcast that i was trying to look into
it he
i believe he just over oxygenated
oxygenated his
body somehow or another i believe yeah
by just breathing it in and then not
moving
at all so he didn't use any of it but he
did like 17 minutes or something like
that yeah
something bonkers like that no [ __ ] 17
minutes is like almost a tv show
yeah that's an episode of modern family
yes it's i think it's 22 minutes for
modern family
yeah because of uh ads that's nuts
that's a long [ __ ] time to hold your
breath so how do you over
accident no it's good question wait what
do you think
he has a ted talk about i'm sure he
probably explained a lot of it but he
had to get his
heart rate down he did it once and it
didn't work and
he panicked they had to go in and save
him oh geez there's a whole thing
because it wasn't easy to get in there
towards the thing he did it but he did
it again
there's just something about a dude like
him that's willing to do
[ __ ] that you you you would be like wait
why are you even doing this
how how can you do it and why are you
doing this like remember when he was
encased in ice yeah
he was encased in ice for like a long
ass time
it's a good angle how long was he
encased in ice for
i want to say more than 24 hours i think
it was a long time because
there was one thing he did in new york
city where people could come up and see
him
he was in a like like water
what
what's in the box grab me one of those
[ __ ] too
thanks dad sir thank you sir my pleasure
what's in the box no no no
how did he do it 70 plus
hours in frozen ice yeah so this them
taking him out
is this the end rescuing him oh shut the
[ __ ] up
he lived in that for 72 hours
let me cry travis is like how is he
doing this i need to be there
[Laughter]
that's how badass it is when you just
stand still for 72 hours
lenny kravitz comes to visit you kravitz
is like yo this guy's [ __ ]
crazy lenny kravitz lives on a farm in
brazil
and he finds out that you're doing some
crazy [ __ ] in ice he shows up
like i need to see this i need to be
there live you sit on top of a pole for
a really long time of course
you know i've seen i've seen something
like this before i don't know if it was
david blaine
but monks do it
and they have a way to like slow
down their metabolism
so they can be up there for weeks and
not eat and not drink
anything what does it say about 34 hours
you stood up there for 34 hours before
jumping down
oh shut the [ __ ] up he stood on that
pole like that for 34 hours
80 feet oh my god i don't like this
you seen him eat glass
it's pretty that's so weird
that's such a weird thing to do eat
glass or stand on them all those things
eat glass
stand up there bees out there on that
pole covered in
ice eating glass for three years
[Laughter]
that's a different kind of person right
the art in that is that we know
it's really hard to do and there's no
way to fake it right
no it's like it's crazy it's not like
illusion
no it's like mental [ __ ] fortitude
yeah so he does illusions too right he's
a real magician right magician
but also can do that like that's just a
mind
that's just that's a different kind of
mind yeah stand there for 34 hours on a
pole
he'd probably be a good fighter he'd
probably be amazing he would never tap
out you've seen this one where he puts a
frog live frog in his belly and like
spits it back out
alive did they x-ray him is that an
x-ray
he has all these differences
oh my god imagine if they did we got to
x-ray the frogs first okay okay i'll let
them out in a couple minutes
first to do the x-ray see nothing but
frogs no organs
it's just frost that's such a bad x-ray
it just doesn't look remotely real
like so uh your x-rays came back how
come the frogs are so clear but you
don't see
anything else
oh it's so stupid it's so stupid
you ever shot the uh boring company
flamethrower
yeah yeah we brand out of juice doesn't
have any juice anymore we gotta refill
the
what is it propane propane yeah we got
to refill the propane oh man they got
[ __ ] rhino at the [ __ ] gas station
hook that [ __ ] up to a [ __ ]
tank i know right yeah we just gotta
hook it up but the thing is like it's
the perfect amount
of propane because it's not very big you
see the tank's very small so
elon probably blew half of it out just
showing it to me
he's crazy are you right out there in
the hallway just blowing this fire
[ __ ] it like this flamethrower
in the middle of the hallway i'm like
bro hi
that's how i met him i met him he comes
in he comes in with a flame floor
legitimately he's the sweetest guy very
very nice guy
sweetest guy yeah hurts me to the core
that him and johnny depp want to duke it
out
what's the b they're both nice guys
there's a there was a woman involved
you know how it is oh the amber
heard johnny's ex-wife was involved with
elon apparently at one point in time
so they don't like each other they would
love each other if they knew each other
i'm out of the game
you know me too i live in utah i just
i'm telling you there he goes pulls it
up connor mcgregor's coach offers to
train elon musk
mcgregor come into this well
who which which one of his coaches is
that
kavanagh because he has a bunch of
coaches
so i can co it is kavanaugh i'm not
tweeted
of course you would kavanagh is cool
i don't think they're gonna fight though
is that a real thing it's
no um it was a joke that elon apparently
said
at one point in time uh maybe i should
have a cage fight with him like
lol you know like that kind of yeah and
then because he was upset at him or
something
you know it's how it goes
what are you gonna do i don't know
everybody's
fighting not everybody but when those
kind of fights happen you're like
i see what happened here this is not
complicated math
you know two good guys i'm so in between
crazy everybody's mad good
it's good to be out of the loop i think
it's really wise that you live out there
i really do
i agree because you're so wild like for
a dude like you it's good to be
in a place where you see nature and it's
probably
in a way it's balancing and it's like
there's um
there's something about the the utah
mountains too like
that's a real mountain range yeah you
see that [ __ ]
all the time when you drive around utah
it's like it's very humbling
it's incredible it's just like you're a
[ __ ]
mm-hmm on the [ __ ] entire globe
also it's like natural art like when you
see mountains they're natural art like
if you drive through the mountains it's
like you're seeing
an art gallery like a nature it's
beautiful to look at and it's free
yeah it does something to you like it
excites you in a weird way like can you
when you can see a waterfall coming off
the side of a mountain and everything's
lush and green you see it go into a
flowing river
man that does a thing to your body it
does a thing to your brain it lights
everything up
and that's the best especially for
making music oh
that makes sense especially for making
music because it's just like
without sounding corny it's like
you you feel like you're a part of
something
bigger but you're so insignificant and
then
you can just say i accept
everything around me yeah and
i'm relaxed and i'm at peace
you know knowing that you're just
the world spinning around you and
everything happens for a reason and you
can just sit there
100 percent peace at ease
and say i don't have to worry you know
like i said earlier
l.a always something going on yeah i i
couldn't do it so
yeah there's and it definitely affected
my creative process
for sure what do you mean like going out
yeah yeah yeah there's always someone
hitting you up and
you know i don't want to speak on behalf
of everyone
in l.a or from l.a but there's a lot of
people who
kind of want to drain you and
well you know what it is man it's not
that they want to drain you
what it is is they're greedy they're
concentrating on themselves
and when they're concentrating on you
know they're trying to make it they're
trying to get something happening
right and they're ambitious and they're
self-centered in that way and i don't
mean that
as a pejorative it's a negative thing
just they're self-centered
so they they always want from you right
and so they're draining
like and when you're successful and
you're a guy who's got a lot going on
they think there's a rub i gotta get i
gotta get the post malone get that rub
right i got to be able to somehow or
another gets what he's got hey man
hit me up hey hey i'm here hey hey hey
let's do that thing
right hey hey hey hey hey hey hey let's
go out hey i want you to meet my friend
right hey hey hey are you like bro i
gotta make music
i'm good at one thing and that's using
auto-tune to sing
you got to make that music
i want you to hear some of the new [ __ ]
i think i would love to
i think i would love to what do you
listen to dude i listen to a lot of [ __ ]
i listen to most like it varies
i go on um streaks of listening to
like i'll get in a gang star streak i'll
listen a lot of uh
classic like run dmc for a while
and then i'll go into like some old
zeppelin and i'll get stuck on zeppelin
for months
yeah and then i'll transfer over to some
old johnny cash and i'll get into that
for a while and then i get into like
i'll get into a moody mode and i'll need
some sheryl crow in my life
yeah i listen to like you're my favorite
mistake i'll get into that kind of music
man and i i
i get into all kinds of [ __ ] i go into
these waves
but most of the time if you had to come
in here on a whim and say what kind of
music's playing it's classic rock
almost always it's always like zeppelin
nothing's wrong with that i'd like
nothing wrong with that at all i like
there's something about the 60s and the
70s
there's something about the fact that
these guys were breaking out
of this mold the society yeah
had carved for them when they were
children and here they are as adults
in the 1960s and they are just buck wild
how heavy is sabbath very heavy
for like just imagine uh like
vinyl like vinyl sabbath like and just
like
here's this record i just picked up from
the store
let's spin that [ __ ] and hope my
parents don't hear it
i'm 25 by the way i can't you probably
listened to sabbath on vinyl
i well i wasn't i definitely have but i
wasn't
the biggest sabbath fan i liked a lot of
[ __ ] that was embarrassing
like i was really into kiss when it was
embarrassing this is great
i love kiss but when i was a kid it was
a problem
like other kids that found out you'd
like kiss like what
really oh yeah why oh my god for
whatever reason
kiss got a weird there's a weird thing
that happened with kiss
this is this is what's interesting they
didn't get any radio play a lot of
people don't know this but when i was a
kid
kiss got no radio play no radio play i
don't know if it's because of politics
or
people just decide they suck because
they wear masks or makeup rather
i don't know i don't know what it was
but for whatever reason it was really
hard to hear a kiss song on the radio
and every now and then you would hear i
want to rock and roll all night and
you'd be like what
it's on the radio this is crazy
ah want a rock and roll like you'd be in
your car driving that would come on
you'd be so excited
because you were a kiss fan and you
don't the kiss didn't get any love
and then as we got older i think people
started
missing it and then kiss made like
reunion tours and they came back
and put the makeup on again and people
got excited and
and then people that were for whatever
reason
not kiss fans in the past became kiss
fans in the present
right but when i was in the 80s it was
like a problem
if you loved kiss people would mock you
in the 80s probably because that's like
[ __ ] metallica like yeah that was
guns and roses
too man you know that was um um i
believe
nirvana came out with never mind
what was that 89 91 was it 91 90
yeah that was around those those years
you know
and that just changed everything like
eddie bravo my friend eddie he's always
saying like that's what killed hair
bands nirvana killed hair bands
yeah it just came he was so deep you're
like jesus christ
like you couldn't listen it was [ __ ]
heavy heavy
[Music]
heavy rape me rape me
heavy singing a song called rape me
heavy
holy [ __ ] it's like
what do you even do that song is so
intense
it's like if you could take a person's
emotions
and their soul and figure out how to
transfer it into into musical notes and
sounds
that's what it sounded like that's it
i mean that's what that's what it
[ __ ] is it's like
[ __ ] everything and here's what i'm
going to say
like here wish we could play this god
damn he's a bad [ __ ]
dave grove crushes it all of them
crushes it
that was cool during the nirvana thing
did you watch my nirvana thing no i
didn't what would you do with nirvana
we did a uh we did a whole
fundraiser when was this this was
[ __ ]
two months ago
but uh i've been i'm out of the loop
since covid there's a lot of [ __ ] i
missed on i missed evil superman
i missed you miss evil you misbullied
superman
i did i missed it all yeah so we did we
did a whole set
and it was cool to see dave give his
approval
and travis barker played drums it was
cool to see chris
uh you know travis is the first guy to
come in here with face tattoos but you
knocked it out of the park oh [ __ ] man
is that a good thing travis is one of
those
[ __ ] i love him in the world
he's so cool he's like a genuinely cool
guy yeah
really interesting like intense like as
good a drummer as he
is you cannot be that good unless you've
got some fire inside of you
yeah you know that dude's got fire
inside of him but he's super cool
yeah i mean but like to be that good
and so [ __ ] into it man he's that
he's [ __ ] got it he
i mean that's the same spirit it's just
like it's a spirit it's just like
[ __ ] you i'm gonna play music yeah and
this is how it's gonna be
and he's a guy who likes old cars too
he's a bet for the same reason
he's an artist yeah he's doesn't have
like a dope blazer like a really cool
custom blazer i think yeah probably
he's got a lot of colors one day i'll be
that cool
i'm working on it it's hard it's hard to
get that cool
it's tough it's it's hard travis
parker's at a high level of cool
because he's like a genuine human there
it is look at that thing
god damn that's sweet holy [ __ ]
look at that that is clean who made that
thing
it's hot travis barker's k5 blazer
custom suv
topless topless show the titty
who made that we should probably
oh the light bar on top is gangster it's
a sick car
yeah that's dead it's got taste
it's got taste does it say the uh the
people who built it
well you're gonna have to google it kid
what is it delmo speed and custom
in burbank california
yeah that's pretty beast car shops are
considered uh they're supposed to be
essential businesses you're allowed to
still work on cars
that's what home sell yeah that's one of
the weirdest things about this pandemic
is what's essential and what's not
essential
like it is who did who gets to decide
exactly exactly is there a vote
who gets to decide it's a it's a strange
amount of power because it's not you
and it's not me no it's a strange amount
of power and what
what's allowed to be open was not like
they had uh bars were open
but then they wouldn't let comedy clubs
open like that's an entertainment venue
but then so is the staple center like
those they're very different things
yeah you know one of them can have 30
people in it
right you know it's like who gets to
decide
your restaurant can open because it's
and outside there's no way in hell you
could figure out how to keep people
apart inside
you just did and did it for a while
right
like who's making the rules yeah that's
the whole that's the i
whenever i touch down my my my friend
was like
yeah all the restaurants just uh put
some chairs and tables on the outside
and
yeah that's what most of them did and
they're very smart they adapted
a lot of them that could do that did
that but a lot of
most of them went under i think it's
more than fifty percent whatever
what if you're addicted to partying then
a nightclub is an essential
business point what do people who are
addicted to partying do what have they
been doing besides partying
who's it to say unregulated parties at
home and that gives people coronavirus
don't they they always hear you always
see that story here's a story you never
see
a bunch of guys got together all of them
got tested
no one had coronavirus they partied they
had a great time nobody got hurt you
know
you know who's doing that story right
now dave chevelle
what dave chappelle's doing is testing
everybody flying everybody out to ohio
putting on these great shows he has
music
he has comedy he has a good [ __ ] time
and he does it outdoors
uh yeah that's what he's doing how's
like it's kind of a wedding it's a
wedding chapel wow
so he's doing it on the stage that
people get married on so it's like a
stage like with the [ __ ] polls and
right steps to get up see that's the
whole [ __ ] that's
for day he wants to do a show he figured
it out
he wants to do a show he needs to do a
show that's an essential
that's an essential thing for him it's
essential for people too because it's a
it's another thing that makes people
feel good it makes them feel good
like they're uh they're doing an
investigation of the chain smokers
like the states involved in this
investigation because they did
essentially
a car show where they did they were on
stage
and there was like 600 cars in the
audience
and they did their show to people in
parked cars like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with
that no why is that bad no
i don't see a lot of cars oh jesus no
there was no they were all
standing around oh so it's supposed to
be in cars and people
just said [ __ ] it let's get out of the
cars and stand but
play that play that let me see what that
is oh jesus christ
this is a dj only a two second video so
it depends wow now it depends on intent
i think bro that's a concert
it depends on intent well are there cars
there
was it a drive-in concert what does it
say the crowd was estimated at 2 000
for the concert at water mill ticket
prices
range from 850 to uber vip options for
25 000
that accommodated rvs all profits
were earmarked for charity that's nice
city state of new york is now probing
the concert
are they probing looting to or just the
concert did they have uh
are they probing what happened in soho
or just uh just i had this
story too i saw recently i just want to
know i'm asking for a friend
700 person airbnb
mansion party flyers going around on
twitter for it
oh my gosh there's a thousand dollar
prize for a twerk contest
well it's hard to twerk but they're
saying that's like you know a
super spreader party or whatever of
course yeah
well i got those [ __ ] that say oh
post malone's here at this nightclub
and i'm not even in town yeah that's
crazy right
[ __ ] like they're using yeah and they
people don't don't get their money back
right people pile into the club yeah
it's so weird now i'm still curious
about that
the chainsmokers deal was it a drive-in
concert
supposedly they sold cars they sold cars
600 so that's not
but that's not on them if the people
got out of the car right that's the
thing like
was it do are you supposed to enforce
that
if they like say here's the thing if
they only had it set up as a concert
without
any enforcement whatsoever on how close
people stood to each other
right whose responsibility is it if
people get out and just start talking
right i guess this is what the
promoter either said i don't know if
they actually talked to them but this is
what they were supposed to have done or
did do
their temperature checks upon entry
um no he said noted that concert goers
went through a temperature check upon
entry was not good enough really
offered hand sanitizer hey jerk off with
this
once parked and had restrooms that were
disinfected every 10 minutes oh
awesome well nine minutes giving people
cooties and then on the 10th some dude
comes in and hoses it down
told buzzfeed there were dividers
separating individual
parties in the pit area and that guests
were also instructed they would not be
allowed to leave their
desert designed well they've
misspelled it must be designated but
it's designed
does uh for any reason other than to use
the restroom but obviously that's not
really what's
but wait what if if if if if it's a
drive-in
show why is there a pit right and also
that the dividers between people that's
horseshit
[ __ ] the air doesn't give a [ __ ] if
there's like a little piece of cardboard
here between you and the people next to
you
that your spit goes through the air and
it gets to them if you got it they got
it
i know and oh and i
i don't think it has to do with the with
the boys in the group
i think it has to do with someone else
what do you think it has to do with
because i know the boys in the group
well it seems like sweet guys
i don't think it's their idea yeah
that's exactly what i think i think
right the total like it was a [ __ ] show
that just got out of [ __ ] hand
also here's the other thing if you get a
bunch of people in their cars drinking
and they're all able to open the door
and just socialize yeah they're going to
do it yeah
and plus before that they're tailgating
right
so people are tailgating before the show
so they're cooking burgers having a
hangout having a good time
having drinks with each other and then
the show starts they're going to get out
of their car and mingle with each other
they made new friends
you just pull up really close just touch
mirrors i mean there is a car a car at
least oh that's a car
dude what's the problem this article the
other one there said that there was
it was safe they swear it was safe it
was safe
other video looked insane well
listen it seems safe if you get away
with it nothing happens
if you get away with it nothing happens
like oh my god it was so safe trust me
it was so safe
yeah you you get a co-vid test and you
find it you don't have it after you go
to that concert you go listen it was so
safe
it was the safest it was not safe no one
even could see it
you don't know if someone has it i told
you my friend jack carr got it
did a [ __ ] book signing he caught it
for a day
a day yeah he kicked it quick he kicked
it in a day
yeah i said it felt like [ __ ] for one
day some people that's weird man
my friend michael yo that's what
happened to his mom michael yo was in
the hospital for a long time man for
like weeks
and his mom got sick for a day one day
right then she kicked it it's a [ __ ]
weird
vibe oh man it's weird even coming in
here getting pricked and
you get nervous yeah [ __ ] it i mean
you're nervous before anything
right yeah for sure that one's a nervous
one like [ __ ] i went over
i wonder if i [ __ ] have it if i have
it but i don't
you don't yay it's nice to know i made
it
nice to know scary [ __ ] disease man
i don't know man it's so weird it's such
a bizarre time here's why it's scary
it's scary in what it's done
no matter what even if you're not scared
of getting it yeah even if you think oh
if i get it it's just gonna make me sick
for a few days i'll kick its ass
even if that's true it's scary for what
it's done to the economy it's scary for
what it's done to civilization
it's in it honestly it's terrifying and
i saw
a sign you can get a fine for not
wearing a mask
yeah and sometimes it's up to 600
[ __ ] bucks
yep yeah it's crazy they're arresting
people for keeping gyms open i've seen
that
the same people that didn't arrest the
looters i think is it the exact same
people
yes
arresting people for opening gyms like
give people that like
there's going to come a certain amount
of time i don't know what that time is
but here we are in august it's basically
august
right and everything's still closed like
how long we gonna do this for
we gonna stay closed for a year are we
gonna stay close for two years
like what's gonna be left nothing
so it's a complicated question because
you don't want people to die and you
don't want people to get
to have right diseases and get sick but
then you have to
everybody has to live their life you
know everybody has to
survive and [ __ ] be able to pay their
[ __ ] bills and
eat exactly so when do you when's that
call get made that's what's complicated
about it and that's what no one
from either this is like one of the most
truly human problems we've ever faced
because no one really knows what the
right thing to do is there'll be a lot
of armchair quarterbacking after it's
over
where people who you know people die
people look back on and say they should
have done this they should have done
that well that's great
and maybe maybe some people had a better
idea of how to handle it
but it's just guessing right now it's
just guessing
yeah it's [ __ ] weird dude it's weird
to me
that there is a it's like me in school
having to [ __ ] tuck in my shirt
or else you get detention or whatever
it's weird to be
forced to wear something right so that's
what you feel about the mask i see what
you're saying
yeah but you know that it does work
right that's what's weird about it
if you wear a good mask it actually does
prevent a lot of transmission apparently
that's all japan
why'd i say it that way japan that's all
japan i was
in the middle of saying japan i stumbled
through it some weird way
necro goblin
are hard sorry um japan
they they didn't shut their economy down
they just wore masks
well i mean that's yeah they didn't
suffer that many deaths either it's
really weird
the um i wonder i would like to see like
a documentary on how
japan uh managed covet 19 because they
did an
insane job maybe as good a job as
anybody yeah
i think there's only a thousand deaths
in all of japan
kyle kalinski was telling me about this
and he sent me some article
if you can't find it i'll send you the
article but it's pretty crazy it's
it's all in how they never shut the
economy down
they just all wore masks everybody
followed the rules
and they contained it that's the and
that's and that no
i mean at the end of the day it all
comes down to
respect for other people sure
right that's what a mask is for right
right it's not
it's not it's not a government thing
it's not like
you shouldn't you're you shouldn't be
forced to wear a mask
but you should wear a mask right yes
yeah you shouldn't should wear them and
that's a good person right and that's
because
i respect you as a fellow human
yeah it has nothing to do with being 600
bucks
that's what it cost that some places
it's 600
i saw what what is it in beverly hills
right now what's the fine for lunch i
saw it
300 no fine for looting
300 bucks for not wearing a mask in
beverly hills definitely you should wear
a mask
just so if people feel better for now i
mean we got to get through this together
no yeah exactly and that's but i don't
know about finding people before and the
other thing was snitching they were
paying people to snitch on people who
weren't social distancing
that was the mayor mayor of mayor of los
angeles
they they were like ordinarily snitches
get stitches but now snitches get
rewards
they were literally giving people money
or
advertising i don't know they ever gave
any money out advertising they would
give
give away rewards for people who turn in
people who are not social
it's like why not just say something to
the guy
hey why not just say hey put your mask
on bob
no that's too complicated you're asking
too much but then you have to
how long is the rebate is it like uh
like you have to mail in like
that's a good question yes i know right
what if they still haven't got paid yet
they feel like a [ __ ] terrible person
like bro i turned you in i need the
money to pay my rent
meanwhile months later the money still
hasn't come
if he is rough and i know i slept in a
closet
three hundred dollars jesus because
maybe someone sees you eating and you
don't have a mask on
and then you stuck with a [ __ ] ticket
yeah that it blows my mind
it's weird it's all about [ __ ] the
responsibility of
and your character really if you snitch
and
they don't pay you what do you do who's
gonna who's gonna want to hear you
whine if you snitch like hey i uh i
turned in with this family next door
they were having a picnic
and uh never got my reward i don't even
know how that works
how about lost dogs do they ever pay
the cash amount they say they want them
they never find them
lost dogs that's dark they're coyote
food
most of the time in l.a that's true when
i drive through my neighborhood and i
see like a poodle on a sign
i just make the sign of the cross that's
it baby
you don't even try you know you don't
even see it and you're like poodle's
gone gotta keep my eyes peeled you don't
understand how many coyotes there are my
neighborhood i've lost
19 chickens i lost 19 chickens in my
neighborhood
out here coyote [ __ ] rough dude
we lost them one at a time these
[ __ ] and then
the the last i guess we had like 11 of
them
left after the fire after
the big fires out here we had uh they
burned down their chicken coop but they
were still alive
and there was like i think 11 of them
left we put them in a smaller chicken
coop while we had the other one
reconstructed and one day the coyotes
got to it
just destroyed it tore open the chicken
coop and ate all the
chickens through the wire yeah they
pulled the wire off they pulled the
the wood off of it they're predators man
yeah they're real smart
they're devious little [ __ ] utah they
don't
do they they don't pay you out here for
dead ones
you get 50 bucks in a year yeah in utah
that's worth it
the thing is you can't kill them they
just keep when you kill them it has the
opposite effect
what happens with coyotes is they do
that roll call where they yell out yeah
yeah yeah
yeah right well when one stops
responding like when one's missing
everybody's checking it out no the one
the females start growing more eggs
no [ __ ] yes so they have more babies so
when female coyote
coyotes are in um what is a clan a pack
when fema female coyotes are in pack and
coyote goes missing
all of the females generate more
children
so if they would normally have like
three kids now they have six
so it's like unlimited money well they
as long as you you have to kill
them all you have to kill them all
because as long as you persecute them
what they do is they make more babies
and they spread out and they're really
smart they're in every [ __ ] city in
this country right now yeah
they're weird they're we got a little
trickster in my
how big big really yeah how big
big mountain lion yeah 150 how big is he
bigger bigger yeah those utah cats are
big because there's so many deer
up there big [ __ ] and
he always comes and hangs out oh jesus
yeah same cat
[ __ ] him big you want to shoot him right
in the [ __ ] deck
i'm not uh no hanging around your house
if i see if i see if i see the ears go
back bro
that's when i'll shoot it they eat dogs
yeah that's what mostly what they do
yeah they find dogs and [ __ ]
things that are easy to eat they're so
creepy well that's the same
i had a i i still do uh
he stays with my parents right now but i
had a micro
french bulldog and smack
for coyotes especially out here whenever
i lived out here
he would go out back and
yeah we heard him all night
it's it's it's scary stuff man
they're a wild a weird wild animal it's
a small wolf
that lives with people and they're just
slippery enough and small enough we're
not worried about them
right just small enough right like if
there was wolves on the street
everywhere we'd be [ __ ] terrified it
would be like little red riding hood and
[ __ ]
because we would know they're going to
kill your kids wolves will kill your
kids right
coyotes are just small enough that we're
like i don't think it's going to kill
the kids
i think we'll be okay right you let
these [ __ ] dirty [ __ ] live
[ __ ] three of them killing your cats
it's [ __ ] insane
killing dogs well that's yeah that's
what i'm saying it
never mind i'm not gonna say that
because uh they're creepy the game
the commission will come after you i'm
not saying anything
i if i see those ears go back yeah well
that's self-defense though
yeah they did a study of um cats in
northern california like outside of san
francisco they captured and
or killed some of these mountain lions
and they did a content
stomach content thing with the troubled
cats the pro you know
they would cause problems eat people's
cats and dogs and [ __ ]
they found out that 50 of their diet was
house pets
it's most of these mountain lions out
there just eating dogs yeah
that's a that it's half their diet man
missing dogs you think about all the
people out here just if you had an
aerial view of people and how these
people have dogs
thousands and thousands of dogs and
these cats are just stealing them out of
backyards yeah
just jumping in stealing them out of
backyards
you never know it happens and people
don't know and they don't know what to
do
they call their friends they put up that
poster
we're just trying to get fluffy back
these photos
we miss them you find them lose money
we have money i just go they ate them
we're surrounded by these creepy
predators
mountain lions no one ever sees right
they're killing
multiple deer a week there's not a lot
of cougars out here
there's plenty just not the fun kind
there's a lot of those kind but there's
also mountain lions
there they have them in griffith park
there's one that they there's a photo of
a one that
i have out there i remember it did you
see the one that i have out there
it's a famous photo of the one it's it's
a huge cat that's walking in front of
the hollywood sign
it has a big collar on it like because
they they gps track them
but this [ __ ] thing is in griffith
park it's right outside look at that
that [ __ ] that giant cat look at
his picture his amazing picture
that cat is in the hollywood hills
name's uh uh chandler
that's mikey
he's huge he's massive it's so big i
wonder what it weighs
isn't that one dead didn't that one die
that one's still alive [ __ ]
what's his really 22 that's his name
that's what they call them
they name them numbers instead of giving
them names because they don't want to
feel bad when they die
urban carnivores look at him that old
warrior
she's out there eating skunks and [ __ ]
oh damn that's a
big [ __ ] that's a big [ __ ] where
where was
it was out here too like wasn't it
that's it the [ __ ] hills
imagine if you're hanging out with
yourself yeah you're sitting on top of
the hill
like let's just get it let's go to make
out point just get out of the car
have a glass of wine you see that thing
coming up the hill right out you're like
[ __ ]
man what do you do what do you do you
break the [ __ ] wine bottle on the
ground
like you're in an old movie [ __ ]
revenant come on [ __ ]
yeah like um the gray remember
did you ever see that one that was a
liam neeson moving the wolves were
coming after him and he broke bottles
and stuck him inside of his knuckles i
did see that movie yeah it's snowy
everywhere
yeah yeah i i'm thinking about
uh leo
fighting the revenue bear yeah you know
that was based on a real guy
that movie was based on a real man it
must have been a [ __ ]
i remember that i love how he has that
like uh
uh cowl neck sweater yeah it looks warm
and comfy
most certainly i'm just [ __ ] killing
a pack of wolves in my [ __ ] cow neck
yeah with broken airplane booze bottles
shoved and airpods didn't have uh
in each knuckle yeah that's what he had
he made like a
makeshift brass knuckles and he's got a
knife he's ready to go to the death with
these wolves
that'll take three seconds
congratulations
good shitty decision making gaff tape
airplane a tree bro
climatry and weight okay the [ __ ]
david blaine can stand still for 38
hours you can't get up in a tree until
these wolves get bored
that's true wolves can't climb trees
[ __ ] climb
how long do you wait for them well it's
one of two decisions either you find out
how long they get bored and you go where
they can't go
or you fight them to the death and that
takes three seconds
you have two choices you gotta fight the
biggest one
bro they act they're gonna tear your
hamstrings apart no you gotta fight the
biggest one because once you fight the
biggest one
they're gonna think you're the you're
the leader of the pack now
the first thing they're gonna do is
they're gonna send some little [ __ ] ass
wolves because it's all it needs to kill
you
and they're gonna eat you [ __ ] first
i would love to i would
love to see a little bitch-ass wolf try
to beat my ass
i would love that
no shot in hell any bitch-ass wolf is
kicking my ass
i want to fight your king take me to
your leader
but getting killed by wolves is probably
one of the worst ways to go
because it takes a while what about like
a va of acid that'd be a bad too that'd
be bad
there's something terrible about some
knowing that something's killing you to
eat you though
you know like wolves killing you to eat
you like you're looking at him like ah
ripping apart your chest some extra
terrifying
you could give him a [ __ ] kick you
could just kick the
wolves into [ __ ] oblivion nonsense
wolves
think about what wolves can do they
they're 150 pounds they can run
35 miles an hour and they can do it for
all day they go all day they're made out
of wire
have you grabbed a hold of a wolf they
don't even feel like they don't even
feel like an animal
get them in the clothes get them in the
clothes yeah good move
what are they gonna do if they can't
bite you they'll call you
yeah that's pretty rough i'm gonna do
some tai chi on them
sidestep imagine if mice took jiu jitsu
they could keep that [ __ ] centipede
from eating them brain first
what a weird world nature is man it's
terrifying
yeah it's just one thing eating
another thing getting eaten by a third
thing
and then what's what's more terrifying
about that centipede eating the mouse
the fact that a centipede does that and
eats a mouse
brain first or the fact that people set
it up
and filmed it knowing how it was going
to go down right and wanting to show
people what happens when a centipede
meets a mouse
so they left this mouse in this total
unnatural environment if that mouse was
out in the wild
centipede probably rarely gets a hold of
a mouse like that
right mouse is faster fast and he knows
jiu-jitsu
like that centipede like go back to that
video with the centipede in the mouse
don't go back through the mouse have a
chance of getting away
in a real world environment they were in
an aquarium it was right
it's but it's not a real world
environment but in a real world
environment
if the mouse had a chance to scramble do
you think you could have got away
because that's the thing it's like is
that a fair fight
like if a big guy is trying to chase
down
a small fast guy in a large area
it's not going to happen he's not going
to catch him no but if you leave him in
a tiny little room
then they can grab him yeah that's kind
of what happened there that's an
unnatural environment yeah it's not
there we go this is it was first
of all graphic got a different version
of this this is a grasshopper house this
is a little more of a fight
oh those are vicious little mice look at
them they're going to war
yeah [ __ ] you oh my god the mouse is
attacking them and biting it and then
jumping away
again holy [ __ ] this is lit very well
and it might be set up
you're right but because i don't know
how you get cameras so good to capture
all this
i think the creepiest part of the whole
deal is his legs dude i'm glad you think
like you do jamie
because you're right this could this is
probably more murder porn
is this one mouth your [ __ ]
head off [ __ ] mouse wins bite your
[ __ ] head off look at him
and then he gets to eat them oh yeah
yeah
that's what they do protein that's they
go out that's where the flavor is
[ __ ] first look at them you don't
need it that's a different kind of mouse
though than those little [ __ ] ass lab
mice that they threw in that aquarium
those little lab mice can we watch a
snake in a mongoose
[Laughter]
mongoose beat the snake too they're fast
yeah monkey says
mongoose is the best bike here we go
as a kid what is this
on centipedes late at night oh this is a
different mouse
oh [ __ ] but not this night oh we clipped
him
a not on this night oh so this night the
centipede wins
oh my god he i poked him look at that
they he hurls himself at the mouse
oh my god the mouse ran off it's like
this is [ __ ]
ugh oh you got to think about it if
you're good that's cool that's cool
what is that kung fu mantis holy [ __ ]
that's a real thing
okay now imagine that the size of a
horse running down central park
taking out people we're so lucky
we're so lucky there are 80 big tiny
things
right no oh yeah for sure dude oh that's
my boy
that bullets would be just bouncing off
that thing
yeah you think about the like
existential
exo skeleton yeah if if
the size you can crush it and you hear
the crunch
but at a larger scale it's probably
bulletproof
yeah you ain't crunching [ __ ] you got a
big one
the size of a horse look at that thing
that's beautiful what is that man
what is it called it's another kind of
mantis i've seen there's there's like a
lot of species of
bro wait are they meant to seize i don't
know
that is one of the craziest looking
insects i've ever seen that's beautiful
wait are they gonna fight it looks like
they're going to war where are they
friends
back up a little bit so i can see the
the the kung fu man is go through his
kung fu
because he actually does do kung fu when
you saw the moves
that the mantis makes when he sees the
other wow look at that man
they're both beautiful they are
god it's amazing but the fact that that
little one oh he got
snatched up son welcome to the jungle
how fast we got fun and games yeah
that's it
it's game over [ __ ] size does and he's
like i'm gonna eat you
that's great you know what this is this
is like
real kung fu like you think you have
like power
over the larger opponent but only so
much there's one too it's a different
kind take it upside down
um well is he uh
oh that's a different mantis yeah they
must be at the mantis zoo
capturing like this is a jumping spider
that's what it's called a little no
there was a picture of a spider in here
somewhere look at that mantis
how many [ __ ] mantises are there
manti
meant to see imagine being a bear
being in a river okay grabbing a fish
and eating it
right alive yeah probably feels amazing
i taste so good you're hungry never know
when your next meal
just biting into a salmon just imagine
okay
imagine being a big mantis and picking
up a little mantis
and eating them and eating in my life in
front of his friends look at that
right in front of his friends [ __ ] you
in your whole neighborhood
i'm eating your friends
[Laughter]
i mean he's enormous that's like a it's
almost like
it's it's like a giraffe eating a person
right
is it as big as he is can we pull up the
grasshopper eating a carrot look at that
one
look at that one what is that called
ghost it's go surreal that is so crazy a
ghost mantis
you do there's a green bean he's on a
leaf
i thought he was on a big green bean
what a trick
what's your favorite vegetable that's a
good question
is it green beans no oh that's mine
garlic snap peas those are really good
are they snap peas yes with garlic on it
and they put
they make them with garlic but what's
your favorite raw vegetable
probably like bell peppers because
they're not really a vegetable they're
like a fruit it's a fruit
is it like a bell pepper fruit or a
vegetable
straight up vegetables i guess i like
green leafy things but i don't know if i
like them or if i know they're good for
you
you try raw green beans they're pretty
good
they're the best okay okay if you got a
plate of
delicious ripe watermelon next to some
[ __ ] ass green beans
which one you're gonna reach for well
depends on if i'm feeling fruity
or if i'm feeling like vegetable
vegetably yeah
i rarely would eat a salad if it was hot
out and it was right next to
like cold oranges right perfect oranges
those you know those oranges when you
you pull this the peel back it just goes
away
it just goes away like it's it's wants
you to eat it yeah you know you don't
have to struggle you know
it's like it's like a silk garb yes on a
beautiful lady yes it just drops
and then you peel those little slices
and put them in your mouth and it's just
this
explosion of moisture and flavor [ __ ]
your green beans bro
hey eat the whole [ __ ] pack of green
beans and you can send a
[ __ ] big wolf i don't want to fight
the little bitch-ass wolf
i get it when people are starving to
death but the fact that you would ever
choose brussels sprouts over a delicious
apple
is ridiculous it's different though it's
just like a good meal flavor
they're different the apple's the way to
go different textures different flavors
for sure i'm not arguing because i
believe it
just seems like something to talk about
are ghosts real
i wonder man so you're friends with zach
he believes in him 100 right it's real
okay but how much of that show that they
do when they're like dude let's go in
the basement
look night vision what was that cut to
commercial like how much of that
how many how many times have they ever
caught an actual ghost on their tv show
a lot come on man i think ghosts are
probably real
but the ghosts that show up on tv are
probably hacks it's real i was like
shitty ghosts
watch my episode i believe you
that uh mama movie that i was talking
about like if that was real
if you see mama at the end at the end of
the movie you get to see like a real
good
image of mama mama's like floating
floating over this
uh this person if that was a real thing
and you didn't have your camera out and
it just went away
and then you had to tell people would
you even tell them yeah
what would you tell them like if you
were you wouldn't even know what to
[ __ ] tell them
you'd just be like you'd probably tell a
few of your friends but you wouldn't get
it on facebook
you wouldn't put it on facebook you
wouldn't put it on instagram
you might tell your friends it's like if
you saw a ufo
if i saw ufo legitimate ufo i saw
something i couldn't explain i'd have to
tell people here
i'd have to you've never seen the ufo no
i don't think so
i don't think so nothing that i
that really stands out i think i thought
i saw something when i was younger but
it
it's not a strong enough memory it could
have been a jet
fighter you know when a fighter jet
flies by you know they do
exercises all the time like there was
one time they launched uh a missile
off the california coast
i forget who what was it edwards air
force base i forget who
who launched it but it was crazy i was
driving down melrose and i saw it fly
across the sky
and everybody thought it was a ufo
people were pulling over they're like
what is that what is that people have
their cameras out they're looking out
the window you see this
streak flying across the sky you
remember spacex launch
i didn't see it in the flash i only saw
it
after the launch and [ __ ] that's pretty
crazy it looked
bizarre did you see it outside yeah
where did it launch from
i have no way somewhere here did it
launch from here
jamie yeah i just saw it online after it
had done it
vandenberg it's in santa barbara okay
and we looked
up and it was just like yeah and we were
like what the
[ __ ] is that what time when was this uh
this was i lived in tarzan the same
place i saw that same place i saw that
17. oh yeah that's right no you know
what i did see this
i did see this too same place i saw that
like
like big ass [ __ ] uh maybe i didn't i
don't remember if i saw this or if i
pretended i saw this we definitely put
it up on the podcast i remember that you
might have seen it on here
yeah i think that's it i think maybe i
knew it was happening
what makes something look like that i
think it's the thrusters
you know giving off fire right there's
fire coming out of the back end of it
and it's
going incredibly fast so it's streaking
through the sky
it's causing a disruption in all of the
um all of the moisture in the atmosphere
so you know you've got something that's
going insanely fast with
an immense amount of power just burning
water just burning water vapor and then
the condensation in the air
like that's what when people get
confused about like oh my god chemtrails
are real look how about the sky
when you see planes and you see those
trails behind them yeah
all that is is the heat of the engine
interacting
with the water vapor that's in the air
the condensation and it creates fake
clouds people like they're making clouds
no
they are making clouds yeah but they're
not doing it on purpose it's just a
byproduct of jet engines
doesn't the kremlin do that definitely
people do that
control weather there's definitely
people who not only do they control
whether in abu dhabi they make it rain
once a week they have 52 weeks of rain
a year in the silicon valley ions and
[ __ ]
it's cloud seeding they use but it's a
science
and cloud seeding is uh 100 verified
science
they've had it forever and they've used
it to manipulate weather in a bunch of
different circumstances they've used it
to cause
rain in places but it's like an
established science it's like
silver the silver something silver
so what is it what is the [ __ ] that they
use
silver surfer yeah they impart
the powers of the silver surfer but they
do something where they spray things
into the sky and it forces the clouds to
coalesce i think i'm doing a shitty job
of explaining it
but they know how to do it in abu dhabi
those dudes do it once uh once a why not
like no [ __ ]
they're like wouldn't it be great if it
rained here once a week i mean it's
great here but would it be great
is it bad it's a good question for earth
you can't play god it says they fly out
and add stuff to a concert that already
has a little rain present then they fire
a salt flare into the cloud to enhance
the rainfall
whoa yeah clouds have two air masses one
is updraft and one is downdraft
what clouds are clouds are alive man
but if i was living there i'd and
someone came to me hey
do you uh we have a service we offer
where we can uh make it rain once a week
like oh yeah once a week yeah well let's
do it man yeah
let's do it so they have 52 weeks of
rainfall yeah
they have like once a week it rains 52
rainfalls a year
everything stays moist smart
if you can do it if it actually works
but what does it do
is it what
what are the long-term effects it's the
tears of all the dead people
what dead people people have died in the
past all of them
that's what it is you're praying for
more tears that's what rain is that's
why seattle's so sad
it's all dead people up there think
about weather
in relation to music is interesting it
is
yeah also heroin use right whether in
relation to heroin use
yeah really yeah specifically heroin in
general or drug use in general
drug use in general but it appears that
like the people that i've talked to that
lived
particularly my friend joey diaz who
lived in the pacific northwest he's like
man it's something about that area where
it's all heroin
a lot of heroin up there and joey you
know he has
a lot of experience with drugs and he
was he lived up there for a bit he was
like dude it's
just a lot of heroin yeah i think it's a
sadness you know the lack of vitamin d
lack of sunlight i mean we didn't
i don't think people really truly
understood how bad that was for you
to be uh vitamin d deficient like that
and the fact that that's the best way we
get it is from the sun
yeah that's why like when you're out at
your place man
and you're in utah there's clear skies
and you just [ __ ]
just just close your eyes and face
towards the sun you feel on your face
like ah
that's nice man that's a love hug
from the universe the fireball in the
sky makes you vitamins
the fireball in the sky is making me
vitamins the fireball in the sky makes
you vitamins that's what it is
it's crazy it is crazy but even in utah
even during
the winter times it's super overcast
and snowing and [ __ ] but
you still get that same kind of vibe
but maybe that's because you experience
the the warmth
utah's not overcast like the pacific
northwest is though
it's yeah close it's like london too
it's like the fog
like the it's heavy and it's dense
you know you know there's something
about that kind of [ __ ] that it's
fun for a while right but after a while
it wears on
every day yeah every day over and over
yeah the dudes that i know that sustain
it they seem
weary you know my friends that i know
from the pacific northwest there's
something about them there's a weariness
to them
that concerns me even the healthy ones
they don't the same weary
i mean maybe this is obviously just the
people that i know but there's something
about them man
i just think you need we need sunlight
it's good for people feels good that's
why you like to go on vacation
like you don't have to live where it's
dreary right and i think
look if you look at the biggest
political upheavals the biggest
these these uh protests that are getting
crazy where they're trying to burn down
courthouses and [ __ ]
it's seattle and portland are the
craziest seattle and portland are way
wilder seattle they took over six blocks
of the town
set up their own government put up their
own borders
use their own security in place of the
police
they wouldn't let people in i mean they
wouldn't let the police in
they they set it up for they were there
for weeks like that
that's not happening anywhere where it's
sunny out
that's that's i think it's more likely
to take place there
it's [ __ ] celestial i suppose like
human behaviors
kind of [ __ ] out of our control and
all uh lies within the environment i
guess
i guess that's not totally accurate
though because they really did [ __ ] up
la too
la went pretty goddamn crazy here
la seems to have calmed down at least a
little bit
whereas it only seems to have ramped up
more in the pacific northwest
but god damn it's beautiful up there in
the summer i
i'm a nut for pine trees pine trees
just like looking at them they're
incredible
and they smell good they do smell good
yeah you wake up in the morning and
even that's why like i don't know if i
could live there
but like being in the northwest the
pacific northwest
is waking up there is special
it does feel different
it's like there's like a certain
right smell in the air
yeah it's nature it's real nature
you know it's unmolested nature what
you're smelling is
the same thing that people smelled if
they lived there a thousand years ago
yeah in utah they're smog and especially
in salt lake
smog gets heavy but we're on that it's
not so bad
but you can see it like sunrise you can
see it
that sucks ellie gets it bad that was
one of the craziest things about kovid
is when the lockdown hit and people
weren't driving they're like the air
quality's never been better
like los angeles air quality is amazing
this is like
people like go outside breathe the air
this is crazy that makes a difference
oh it makes a huge difference if cars
aren't driving it makes a huge
difference
it's probably a big part of the problem
here
and that's also going to be a good
argument for electric cars and it's also
going to be a good argument for
autonomous vehicles
less fires and accidents and [ __ ] where
are you from
i was born in new jersey and mostly grew
up in boston
yeah but i lived out here for a while i
lived in california when i was a little
cats fan are you
i don't like sports sports are wack i
don't know anything about them
i'm a professional sports commentator
who doesn't know the rules to sports
i appreciate the athletes i appreciate
what they do like
i i you know enjoy watching like michael
jordan highlights or kobe bryant
highlights or something like that
or football players who do crazy [ __ ] i
love watching them but
dallas cowboys i don't [ __ ] this it's
not a it's not because it's not exciting
i've watched super bowls before they're
[ __ ] exciting
but there's only so much time in a day
and i already
my schedule's full full up with [ __ ] i'm
interested in
i can't get into i can't start following
the nba
try to figure out all the games or major
league baseball oh well there's a
national league
i don't know [ __ ] american league
like what i don't know how baseball
works
they play so many damn games they play
so many games then who's in the playoffs
and why
it's like what's happening here but it
gives the people a lot of [ __ ]
entertainment man
if you're bored you know like for a lot
of folks that are stuck in a shitty job
just like we were talking about driving
that 68 charger or a 68
camaro to work for a lot of dudes stuck
in a in a job that doesn't give them any
thrills and they know they have to go
they have to be up in the morning they
don't have time for anything other than
watching something and they can watch a
basketball game and get very invested
in the fact that they want their team to
win or watch a football game or a
baseball game
right they get invested come on patriots
no come on where let me crack what do
you got
what do you got there oh [ __ ] yeah
dallas
yes dallas he's a cowboys fan i can tell
jamie's from columbus ohio guys
got some good buckeyes on the cowboys
yeah of course everything comes out of
ohio there's something weird about ohio
yeah football's an awesome sport i wish
it didn't
[ __ ] people's brains up as much but
that's just how it is with everything
everything everything dangerous
everything risky
you run the risk of getting injured i
just hope they figure out a way to fix
brains
you know fix brains or fix helmets i
don't think that's going to help
when you see some of these guys the the
speed that they run at each other
and they're colliding you just the
[ __ ] physical strength that these
people have if you
saw what zeke run and if i watch zeke
run
and i see this god zeke just takes a
[ __ ] hit
dude [ __ ] top and i'm like
are you okay and then he gets right up
and does it again
it's it's it's like so much respect to
[ __ ]
to fighters to [ __ ] football players
basketball players everybody
absolutely they all deserve a lot of
respect but this is just a danger
to football i think that's not in as
many other
this is just my looking at it like
there's a real danger to fighting
there's no doubt
but in fighting it's there's a person in
front of you
and they're trying to do stuff to you
and you should know how to avoid it if
you don't that's just how the game works
but in football there's like dudes
running at each other
i mean you're gonna get hit yeah 20
miles an hour they're going so fast
they're so strong
and they're running at you and you're
running and they're running and this
boom
what about rugby what about rugby
there's something pure about that right
because they don't have the pads
i don't think people would attack the
way they attack now
if there's no pads that's an argument
for football that's a weird argument
right because like make them play with
no helmets
and see how they play like yikes
i think they start i was looking at this
one time i think that like the football
protection started from different
injuries like brain injuries were
obviously never
a worry spinal injury injuries are huge
in rugby
and they were big and football before
too like the injuries were what they
were trying to prevent for a while
people get paralyzed and you show that
on tv it's scary as
off [ __ ] that makes sense
wow so what do you risk do you risk
that or the brain damage
but that i don't know because there's
people who
are so passionate about it a hundred
percent
yeah no like nobody never i would never
say they shouldn't be able to do it
yeah but people should know what it is
you know when you when you're playing it
what was the movie that will smith did
yeah concussion that was based on an
actual doctor who
had figured out what was going on the
you know it's a [ __ ] amazing sport
though
when when it's going when you're
watching crazy [ __ ] happen on the field
and you want you're like i need to be
there and see one live
because that's probably when you really
get an understanding we'll go to 18
biggest stadium in the world right
pretty much that's what
this so god can watch the roof oh but so
guys are you allowed to be there live
no not yet will be well like will you be
ohio stadium is saying they're going to
have 20 capacity
maybe i don't know how much those
tickets are going to be how rare they'll
be or whatever but
people probably will be able to be in
person at football games if they happen
a limited number of people but god
that's so weird
you know it was bizarre too watching the
last ufc
no one in the [ __ ] audience strange
right
and you get to hear those [ __ ]
getting
like [ __ ] just cracked on the head
dude it's like there's something very
exciting about it man
it's something i almost like about it
more um
watching it that way yeah it's kind of
like
you're more there well it's just there's
no
there's no denying that um like a big
crowd
an awesome crowd like a conor mcgregor
crowd is crazy
it's a spectacle to see you know when
you're seeing all those people screaming
and cheering and
i remember he had senator connor sing
for him i was like holy [ __ ] man there's
like
green smoke in the air and everything
like it was amazing and everybody's
going crazy when connor makes his way to
the cage
everybody's like wwe it's just the
energy in the room is undeniable i mean
it's amazing
but there's also something amazing about
these two dudes in front of each other
right where there's no crowd
no one around and you hear everything
you hear all the impacts you hear them
breathing you hear the [ __ ] [ __ ] to
each other
the the coaches the the corners and
everybody yeah everything
it's so different man it almost makes
you think that this is like really kind
of the best way to do it
like i want people to be able to see it
live for sure
but there's something about there's a
purity
to no audience this is what i'm saying
this from a real selfish place right
because i get to be there
and i get it and i'm i if yeah i mean if
they could open it up and it would be
safe and everybody could sell tickets
don't
100 would want the audience to be full
don't get me wrong but there's something
about
when you're there and there's no
audience right that you're
you feel first of all you feel very
lucky i feel very very lucky to be there
like man there's only like 10 people in
the room
watching tyron woodley versus gilbert
burns
right with 10 people and i'm one of
these 10 people calling this [ __ ] that's
crazy
but then there's also uh
there's there's nothing influencing it's
just the fight man
there's no roar of the crowd there's
nothing
nothing it's just the fight and when you
when it's just a fight man you see it
break
it's so clean like you see it all break
down more and
how much does that affect performance um
i wonder asking you
i wonder i think people vary i think
some people feed off the crowd and they
love it they love the pressure and then
some people they're better off if
there's no crowd right
some people probably fight better it's
like almost like a uh
sparring session in an empty gym you
know there's no one there
sometimes sometimes the physical
people in front of you like just 20 000
people screaming and cheering for george
st
pierre and you're like [ __ ] and you got
to realize like you have to perform all
these people hate you
they all want you to lose and they'll
stand there watching you about to fight
one of the
you know greatest fighters of all time
if you're going to fight george st
pierre you gotta get your ass kicked
is he a nice guy he's a super nice guy i
want him to be a nice guy he
is as nice as possible is my [ __ ]
that guy is a real warrior in the best
sense of the word meaning like if you
wanted to have your kid
emulate someone who's a martial artist
a gentleman a really interesting person
who thinks a lot about things and treats
martial arts as
an art form and a discipline and a way
to express himself in a way to
show that he could be the best like he's
as positive a human being as you're ever
going to meet
george c pierre is like so positive in
so many ways
he's such a nice guy and undeniably one
of the best fighters of all time
yeah there's no [ __ ] but such a nice
guy like people would
they would uh take him for granted
yeah until it's too late
he's so nice he wouldn't realize like
this guy's a killer he's a [ __ ]
killer yeah
but when you're around him like he's so
nice like you can't believe he beats
people up for a living
he gets that [ __ ] out inside the cage i
saw anderson silva once in london
oh yeah do you see him fight no no you
saw him
i just saw him at the airport i saw him
at heathrow
and i was another super super nice guy
yeah
anderson is so nice he's one of my faves
he's so friendly
is he he's so nice very very very nice
i got to see anderson when he first
burst i was a fan of anderson's before
he made it to the ufc
he was fighting cage rage in the uk he
was dominating people i was watching
these
these videos online i was like god damn
this guy is amazing i remember he fought
for pride too
but he was getting better and then he it
all came together for him during the the
years he was fighting in the uk and
that's when everybody had their eye on
him and he beat
lee murray and he beat jorge rivera i
mean he was a
monster tony frickland he hit him with
this crazy elbow that he practiced
that crazy upward step in upward elbow
he's a he was a wizard so when he came
over to the ufc we caught him
right at his prime and he's it's
arguable
that prime anderson silva was the best
martial artist ever
it's real arguable when he knocked out
vitor belfort with that front kick to
the face
i mean some of the [ __ ] that he did man
some of the knockouts that he had like
he had
esp he knew where people were going to
be right he had knuckles waiting for him
right he was when he was on and no
fighter can stay on that level for very
long the human body just breaks down
but there's a time where anderson was so
good
i'd put him up against anybody that ever
lived
there was a time it was a few years
where the rich franklin years like
anderson was unstoppable
where did where did he fight at where
what did he fight at what weight 185
was 185 so he's probably really walked
around like 200 plus pounds and we'd
cut weight towards so what is that light
that's middleweight he was little
champion yeah i i would like to see john
and anderson
that would have been an amazing fight in
its day it would be
not a good fight now right john's in his
prime and anderson is
you know i think right no but like prime
time like
it would have been interesting john is a
big man
they they they i i met john he's a sweet
sweet dude super sweet guy and uh john
is a big man though
yeah he's big he's from rochester he's
from where my grandparents live
he could easily be a heavyweight easily
if you wanted to
if he decided he's like he's one of
those guys that could
go easily back and forth between 205 and
heavyweight right if he decided to take
enough time to do it
he's [ __ ] strong as [ __ ] when you
watch him grab guys and ragdom
around there's a there's a weird
strength to him
that you see with some of these really
elite grapplers
some of these guys like when you see
like top of the food chain grapplers
like yoel romero
there's like something about grabbing
people your whole life and throw it
around like brock lesnar
he's grabbing people's strengths
lesnar's a [ __ ] dog
he was ridiculous he was ridiculous yeah
dude he was so powerful yeah that
[ __ ]
these what are these everything traps
the trapezius
he was like 43 traps
he's so strong he's such a big human
being man
like that [ __ ] man that's grown in a lab
that's some viking dna right there man
that's nuts
that's the lab of the sea created that
thing
that's 100 viking dna if you ever want
to know what vikings looked like
when they were terrified he's [ __ ]
brock lesnar yeah
somebody yeah yeah look at them come on
son look at those [ __ ]
a brass knuckle sword up the top of you
yeah that is
that is the hardest tattoo too oh it's
hard as [ __ ] [ __ ]
trench knife just running up his [ __ ]
chest
doesn't it say death clutch on his back
or something too
there's some some google what's on his
back he's got some crazy [ __ ] on his
back
just google brock lesnar's back
yeah his back has like a skull yeah
click it
there there it is that's his back yeah
yeah
it's got meat hooks
dripping zombie meat hooks and below it
is like a yeah like a demon head like
okay
i love how they put the little bit of
blonde yeah and the in the
in the the black and white photos
of him yeah come on man that is one of
the most preposterous humans that has
ever existed
i'm trying to look come on it's perfect
look at the size of brock lesnar
that [ __ ] was so big man
the fact that this guy got your dad you
got to think of all his accomplishments
because someone put a a
video up about him and it showed all the
[ __ ] that he did
he won a national championship ncaa
division one
all national championship in wrestling
he
went on to play for the minnesota
vikings
he went yes yes when he played
i don't know he was on field he got a
tackle there's a video of it
then he went it was the minnesota
vikings right he's a minnesota guy in
camp yeah
yeah oh so it was in training camp so it
was not a an official game i don't think
so i think it was like a
training like a scrimmage something like
that
so okay pre-season game so he played
pre-season at least for the vikings
plain what linebacker
but it was the vikings right so so he
goes
from there to the wwe then
he goes from the wwe to the [ __ ] ufc
heavyweight championship of the world
yeah i mean
there it is why he's jersey number 69
too
i like his style that's the funniest
thing that's a funny number
69 bro you know how to do it yeah
yeah respect defensive tackle
so you have to i mean like legitimately
wonder like how does one
how does one make a human like that
you know how many humans first have ever
existed crispr
just all the [ __ ] that he's done that's
[ __ ] crazy
yeah you need to crisper him before he
dies
because we if we have an army of brock
lesnar's yeah
bulletproof brock lesnar's that's what
everybody's going to be is he a nice guy
very nice guy yeah a very nice guy he
has a beautiful smile
like a pure smile you know what he is
man he's a guy who wants challenges
you know to to do what he did when he
was a wwe champion
so he's the champion of this uh
wrestling entertainment thing
and then he goes from that into the ufc
and wins the real heavyweight title
right and beats a legend in randy
couture
yes that's bananas that's crazy
that's so rare that a guy can do so many
[ __ ] things yeah
crazy what's his style what what is he
like what's his name
he's a wrestler right he can do
everything i mean he can strike for sure
he's not guys out
he uh he's got ridiculous submissions he
crushes people's heads
just a huge man i mean it's like there's
not a whole lot of
you have to be really good to beat a guy
like that and guys have beaten him he's
he got tapped by frank mirror got him in
a leg lock caught him
didn't really understand submissions and
aleister overeem beat him
after he had uh aleister over from
surgery dog
yeah okay when when he was at his best
he was a terrifying guy too
terry brock lesnar is the the battle of
the specimens have you ever seen that
fight between him and brock lesnar
with uh yeah yeah that was the battle of
the specimens
that was that's a strong ass
[ __ ]
he didn't even put any anything into
that punch too what has to do is land
he's so big this was you know randy
couture too you're talking about
a guy who's one of the all-time greats
he's on the mount rushmore for sure
that's how big brock lesnar is i talked
to randy about it after he goes that was
a big sum [ __ ] where is he from
brock lesnar from nebraska no [ __ ] yeah
he's a viking definitely
if you got some dna on that dude oh my
god and he's fat yeah yo
he's caring he's very fast well he's
just a spectacular athlete
i mean you gotta you gotta deal with
some crazy [ __ ] with this guy
he's a big fella and again he did lose
some fights but you gotta realize all
the [ __ ] he was doing
instead of fighting for so long if brock
lesnar had just decided to fight
from the time he left college if he
never did football
if he he never [ __ ] with anything else
outside of actual fighting
fighting and just started smashing
people oh my god
who knows how good he could have gotten
like when he was in college if he just
embraced mma the way he embraced
wrestling
who knows i mean he this is when he beat
frank muir up that was a particularly
brutal knockout
i mean he was an undeniable man
it just might makes you wonder with a
guy like that what if he started earlier
because
within his first few fights as a
professional
he was the heavyweight champion i think
it was like really early in his career
like go go to uh his uh mixed martial
arts record
how many fights he had oh that's what i
wanted to ask you too does that carry
over
what does what carry over so
uh wins losses that carry carries over
from
each program or each
uh show so if it's like bellator or
anything
so you fight for bellator and then you
go to the ufc
they have con they have contracts so
like if you're a ballator fighter you
would be contractually obligated to
fight only for bellator
no right but do those wins from bellator
carry over
for sure yeah and that and that's across
all yeah yeah all organizations yeah
it's your professional record
and then you know they'll have like a
bellator record or a ufc record
so it was his fourth fight fourth fight
as a professional he won the world title
for randy couture that's crazy wow crazy
they def he beat uh frank muir to defend
it who's a
fantastic champion shane carwin another
amazing champion
then he lost to game velasquez and lost
to alistair
and then he beat mark hunt and then he
retired i love mark hunt too
mark hunt was awesome i love max
holloway
he's amazing kickboxer too mark hunt
like in k1
he was probably at his best he was a k1
grand prix champion
you know i mean he really learned like
the wrestling the jiu jitsu and all that
stuff
later on you know when he was a
kickboxer he was one of the best alive
he's a tank too man big guy yeah he's
like 5 10 but he's like that wide
big guy again that's like
you know you got your samoan dna
you got your viking dna stout folk
stout folk we should probably end this
podcast just [ __ ] fighting
oh yeah it's probably like it's been how
many hours four hours
we in four jesus wow talking up storm
son
well i had to pee i did too
this was fun man this is a ridiculous
[ __ ] session it was right yeah
what an incredible [ __ ] it was
really good i enjoyed it i enjoyed the
bud light
enjoyed your company um thanks man thank
you thank you
all right bye everybody see ya
we've done that for four hours
[Music]
cheers